Hallo und herzlich Willkommen bei Raumzeit, dem Podcast von ESA und DLR. Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und ich begrüße alle hier zur mittlerweile neunzehnten Ausgabe dieser Sendereihe, wo wir in ausführlichen Gesprächen einen Einblick in die Raumfahrt wagen und immer wieder aufs Neue in neue Themen vorstoßen, von denen viele untrennbar mit ESA und DLR auch verbunden sind. Heute allerdings wollen wir aus aktuellem Anlass mal ein wenig ausscheren aus diesem Fokus und uns eines Systems annehmen, was ja in aller Munde ist und schon auch immer war, nämlich dem Space Transportation System oder viel besser bekannt unter dem Namen Space Shuttle der NASA. Ein System, was jetzt über lange Zeit der Raumfahrt international gedient hat. Und ja, dazu begrüße ich hier als Gesprächspartner Volker, Volker Zubik. Ehemaliger Mitarbeiter des DLR muss man sagen. Der Ruhestand ist eingeleitet, aber lange Zeit dabei gewesen.
Genau, also ich habe bis zum 30. September 2010 als Mitarbeiter im DLR gearbeitet. War dort die letzten Jahre stellvertretender Leiter der Abteilung bemannte Raumfahrt, ISS und Exploration. Name ist Programm. Wir haben uns in dieser Abteilung mit diesen drei Dingen beschäftigt. Wir haben im Rahmen, im Auftrag der Bundesregierung das Deutsche Raumfahrtprogramm verantwortet, vorbereitet und auch durchgeführt. Und wir waren eben in unserer Abteilung dafür zuständig für den ESA-Teil, wo wir unsere Beiträge einzahlen und dann natürlich auch für das deutsche Nationale Raumfahrtprogramm.
Was heißt genau Exploration?
Exploration heißt über den Low Earth Orbit hinaus, wie man so schön sagt, über den nahen Weltraum, jenseits der Raumstation. Was machen wir nach der Raumstation? Richtung Mond, vielleicht wieder zurück zum Mond, Richtung Mars, Stichwort Exo-Mars. Man hat ja vor 2013 und 2016 eine Sonne zum Mars zu schicken, Raumschiffe zusammen mit den Amerikanern. Das ist zur Zeit in der Planung. Also das ist Exploration. Alles, was jenseits der ISS nach außen geht in Richtung Planeten.
Aber die ISS ist im gleichen Maße ein Thema gewesen, natürlich in den letzten Jahren, weil das ja einfach die permanente, dauerhafte bemannte Raumfahrt ist, die derzeit betrieben wird. Da hat man halt auch immer Leute vor Ort, während die anderen eben auch nur ab und zu mal vorbeischauen. Inwiefern hat man denn da jetzt eine Verbindung zur NASA? Also inwiefern dockt man denn da mit den Aktivitäten der NASA eigentlich an, von der Position aus, wenn man jetzt für DLR und ESA plant?
Ja, also wir bereiten zum Beispiel wissenschaftliche Experimente vor. Und es ist ja heutzutage so, in der globalen Raumfahrt, dass wir nicht nur nationale Experimente vorbereiten, wo deutsche Wissenschaftler, DLR-Wissenschaftler oder Wissenschaftler aus deutschen Universitäten beteiligt sind, sondern eben auch durchaus auch Experimente, die also Wissenschaftler aus vielen Ländern umfassen. Und dann kommt man natürlich auch schnell zu den Amerikanern, dann kommt man zu NASA. Wir haben natürlich auch dadurch, dass Deutschland, gerade was die bemannte Raumfahrt anbelangt, ja doch führend in Europa ist, schon immer, schon sehr lange mit der NASA zusammengearbeitet, rückwirkend bis in die 70er Jahre. Das heißt, wir haben uns damals beteiligt an einem, an dem Post-Apollo-Programm der NASA. Das heißt, wir haben für das Shuttle, auf das wir ja nun sicherlich gleich dann auch ausführlicher kommen, zum Beispiel ein Labor gebaut, das Space Lab. Und das waren unsere, sagen wir, in der bemannten Raumfahrt die ersten Ansätze mit der Zusammenarbeit mit der NASA.
Das heißt, darüber hat sich dann, also über die Projekte hat sich das Zwangsläufchen entwickelt?
Über die Projekte hat sich das Zwangsläufchen entwickelt, genau.
Vielleicht noch mal kurz bei Ihnen zu bleiben. Stellvertretender Leiter bemanter Raumfahrt, das wird ja nicht gerade der Einstiegsjob beim DLR gewesen sein.
Nein, das ist richtig. Ich bin eigentlich von Hause aus. Studierter Biologe, habe in Bonn studiert. Und bin eigentlich Mitte der 70er Jahre, noch während meiner Studienzeit, während in der Diplomarbeit und auch nachher bei der Promotion, auf ein Thema gekommen, was schon nachher später dann auch sehr wichtig auch für das DLR war, für die Wissenschaft, nämlich die Gravitationsforschung, Gravitationsbiologie in dem Fall. Also Schwerelosigkeitsforschung. Das heißt, ich war am Anfang Wissenschaftler an der Uni, bin dann sehr schnell in das damalige DLR reingewachsen, weil ich dort die Möglichkeit hatte, meine Feldversuche zu machen, zu dem Bereich Gravitationsbiologie, zu dem Experiment. Daraus ergab sich dann später, dass ich die Möglichkeit hatte, als die Experimente für Spacelab D1, für die erste deutsche Spacelab-Mission ausgewählt wurden, dass ich die Möglichkeit hatte, auf Spacelab-Mission D1 ein Experiment zu fliegen, also selbst als Wissenschaftler zu fliegen. Nicht selbst dort oben, sondern das Experiment natürlich.
Man sagt zu fliegen, wenn das eigene Gerät oben ist.
Genau. Und da bin ich dann eigentlich schon in die Raumfahrt eingestiegen. Das war ja 1985 die D1-Mission. 1993 gab es dann den Nachfolger, die D2, die Deutsche Spacelab-Mission D2. Dort war ich dann nicht mehr Wissenschaftler, sondern bin dann ins Management reingerutscht und war so genannter Nutzlastelement-Manager. Das heißt, ich habe ein großes Nutzlast-Rec unter meiner Verantwortung gehabt, das sogenannte Biolabor. Ich bin bei der Biologie geblieben. Dort wurden dann also viele biologische Experimente gemacht. Ich habe dann natürlich auch etwas näher das System Shuttle kennengelernt, auch an Ort und Stelle eben in Amerika, im Kennedy Space Center. Ich bin dann aus der Projektarbeit dann mehr in die Programme gekommen, also gerade auch in die internationalen Programme. Ich habe mich dann insbesondere beschäftigt, als die ISS dann auch so weit war, mit der Nutzung der ISS. Was kann man oben auf der ISS machen? Wie können wir, welche Geräte sind dafür nützlich, um dort oben vernünftige Experimente zu machen? Wie können wir unsere Forschung, unsere DLR-Forschung, die wir machen, in die ESA einbringen? Uns dort auch durchsetzen und auch entsprechend unsere Wissenschaftler in der ESA und dann auf den entsprechenden Flügen auch gut unterbringen. Das war auch so meine Arbeit in den letzten Jahren.
Man plant weniger die Experimente, sondern man plant mehr für Experimente.
Genau.
Die Infrastruktur.
Planung für die Wissenschaftler. Für unsere Wissenschaftler.
Ja, jetzt haben wir es ja schon am Rande erwähnt. Irgendwann kam auch das Space Shuttle da mit rein. Habt ihr das richtig verstanden? Im Wesentlichen durch diese Mission Space Lab. Das war so...
Also bei mir war es so, wenn ich sagen kann. Ich bin persönlich die ersten Einsätze des Space Shuttles, die Entwicklungen, die politischen Dinge, die dahinterstehen, um zu diesem System zu kommen. Die verfolgte man natürlich auch als junger Mann, als junger Wissenschaftler. Aber so richtig dann konkret mit dem Shuttle und das, was es kann, bin ich eigentlich erst gekommen, nachdem ich auch Experimentator geworden bin und nachdem sich eben ESA Europa mit dem Space Lab beteiligt hat. Das heißt, das war ja erst überhaupt die Möglichkeit, auch für die Amerikaner, den Space Shuttle wissenschaftlich zu nutzen. Das war die erste Möglichkeit, dass das Space Shuttle mithilfe des Raumlabors wissenschaftlich zu nutzen. Jetzt unabhängig von dem, was der Shuttle gemacht hat, Satelliten früher auszusetzen und so. Aber wissenschaftliche Arbeit im Weltraum, das hat Space Lab gebracht.
Da wird einem nochmal klar, was der Name ja eigentlich auch sagt. Also Space Transportation System. Eigentlich ist das Ding so eine Art Weltraumlastwagen.
Genau. Das bringt dann also eben dann deswegen auch Space Lab, Raumlabor. Das ist eben das Vehikel, um dann entsprechend dieses Labor dort oben hinzubringen in den nahen Weltraum. Und dort eben die Umgebungsbedingungen, die dort oben herrschen, zu nutzen, um Experimente zu machen. Ganz unterschiedliche Art, aus ganz unterschiedlichen Gebieten. Von der Materialwissenschaft über die Biologie hin bis zur Technologie. Man macht natürlich nicht nur Grundlagenforschung dort oben, sondern es werden durchaus auch Materialien geprüft, neue Technologien entwickelt. Und das war eben die Möglichkeit, mit dem Spacelab, mit dem Raumlabor D1, dort richtig kräftig zu beginnen. Auch für Europa, insbesondere aber auch für Deutschland. Denn es war ja eine Mission, die unter erstmalig überhaupt in der Entwicklung des Shuttles und auch in der Zusammenarbeit mit den Amerikanern, dass Deutschland und auch das DLR, damals DVLR, eine Mission geführt hat, wissenschaftlich geführt hat. Damals war dann ja auch in Oberpfaffenhofen, das Kontrollzentrum ist ja damals aufgebaut worden, auch für diese Zwecke. Also alles, was wissenschaftlich im Shuttle gelaufen ist, im Raumlabor, ist über Deutschland, über die deutsche Schiene gelaufen.
Das Raumzentrum in Oberpfaffenhofen ist überhaupt erst für Space Lab gegründet worden? Und von daher auch verständlich, dass das heute für die Columbus-Mission zum Beispiel in der ISS weiterverwendet wird? Ja, der Shuttle. Vielleicht bevor wir nochmal auf diesen speziellen Aspekt der Verbindung mit Europa und Deutschland kommen, Space Lab etc., vielleicht mal so ein bisschen einen Blick in die Zeit, was das Shuttle-Programm jetzt als solches betraf. Was hat denn die Amerikaner überhaupt erwogen, diesen Shuttle zu bauen? Was hat ihnen gesagt, wir brauchen jetzt hier so einen Weltraumlastwagen?
Also es war ja so, mit dem Apollo-Projekt hat ja in Zeiten des Kalten Krieges nun Amerika wieder die erste Stelle übernommen. Die Sputtligschande wurde ausgemerzt. Und noch bevor überhaupt in 1969 im Juli die erste Mondlandung war, hat sich der damalige Präsident schon überlegt, und man hat sich nicht nur der Präsident, man hat sich überlegt in Amerika, was machen wir nach Apollo? Und da kam man eben auf die Idee zu sagen, interessant wäre ja, wenn wir eine wiederverwendbare Raumfähre hätten, die eine Raumstation, die wir dort oben aufbauen, dann versorgen kann und aufbauen kann. Das war eigentlich der Grundtenor.
Von vornherein war Raumstation...
Von vornherein war erst mal, man hatte erst mal gesagt, okay, wir wollen einen Shuttle und wir wollen eine Raumstation, die dieses Shuttle bedient. Aber...
Zu dem Zeitpunkt waren die Russen ja beim Thema Raumstation schon sehr weit fortgeschritten.
Die waren schon sehr weit fortgeschritten, sodass man dann sagte, okay, da haben wir jetzt dann aber keine Kohlen mehr am Feuer zurzeit. Also das heißt, wir nutzen dieses Shuttle, wir bauen dieses Shuttle, um zum Beispiel kommerziellen Satellitentransport zu betreiben. Das heißt, dieses System-Shuttle sollte sich eigentlich über die kommerzielle Schiene selbst tragen, finanziell. Man hat dann eine Arbeitsgruppe eingerichtet, die dann verschiedene Shuttle-Möglichkeiten auslotete, technische Möglichkeiten. Es gab also eine Phase, in der die Konzepte überarbeitet wurden. Man kam dann sehr schnell auf ein Gerät, das also Delta-Flügel haben sollte, eine möglichst große Nutzlast fliegen sollte, möglicherweise sogar 20 Leute transportieren sollte. Zum Teil war man in einer Zeit, wo man Utopien aufgebaut hat. Man stellte sich sehr schnell heraus, dass das also gar nicht finanziell zu stemmen war.
Wenn es finanziell zu stemmen gewesen wäre, wäre das nur unter den selben Entbehrungen, die dieses ganze Apollo-Programm mit sich gebracht hat.
Genau, denn während des Apollo-Programms wurden die Kosten schon langsam zurückgefahren. 1966 war das Apollo-Programm schon nicht mehr so finanziert wie die Jahre davor. Dann kam aber jetzt als Glücksfall dazu, dass auch das Militär, also die US-Luftwaffe, sich für so ein System interessierte. Denn in der Zeit war, das war die Zeit der großen Spionagesatelliten, man muss ja unbedingt wissen, was tut sich bei unserem Erzfeind. Dann hat sich also die Luftwaffe damit eingeklingt. Das hat natürlich insgesamt das Shuttle gegenüber der Regierung ein größeres Gewicht gegeben. Die NASA, aber die Konzepte, die sich trotzdem daraus entwickelten, waren zum Teil auch nicht zu finanzieren. Man ging auch von ganz unterschiedlichen Ansätzen aus. Man hatte mal vor, man dachte, wenn wir bauen dieses System, wir bauen fünf Shuttle und diese Shuttle können 60 Mal im Jahr starten. Und dann haben wir also kommerzielle Payloads da drin, Satelliten und das läuft alles bestens. Man merkte schon sehr schnell, nachdem dann eine Entscheidung getroffen worden war, hat man dann sich doch beschieden, indem man sagte, wir bauen ein Shuttle, was rund 20 bis 24 Tonnen Nutzlast tragen kann in den nahen Weltraum, so zwischen 350 und 650 Kilometern.
Was eine Menge ist.
Was eine Menge ist, das hat es bis damals noch nicht gegeben. Aber man glaubte aber so viel haben zu müssen, so viel Nutzlast, um eben diese großen Satelliten, die in der Zeit konzipiert worden sind, auch gebaut worden sind, auch von der Luftwaffe und vom Militär, dass man die auch transportieren konnte. Und man hatte eben dann auch die Idee, diese Satelliten nicht nur nach oben zu bringen, sie dann auszusetzen und in die entsprechende Umlaufbahn zu bringen, sondern sie möglicherweise auch reparieren zu können. Wir sind ja in der Zeit damals in dem Anfang der 70er, Ende der 70er, Anfang der 80er Jahre, wo auf diesen Spionage-Satelliten zum Beispiel gefilmt wurde, noch mit richtigen Filmen. Das heißt, wenn die Filme voll waren, war der Satellit nutzlos.
Muss man also wieder austauschen?
Man musste austauschen und das machte eben auch für die Militärs den Shuttle sehr interessant. Man hatte auch die Idee, wenn mal so ein Satellit irgendwie mal kaputt geht, könnte man vielleicht hochgehen, ihn einfangen, reparieren. Und dann kam man eben dazu, dass eben 1972 dann die Firma Boeing anfing, diesen Shuttle zu bauen. 1979 wurde er dann ausgeliefert an die NASA. Und 1981 gab es dann den ersten Flug. Und dieser erste Flug war was ganz Besonderes. Denn es war das erste Mal, dass ein System, was eigentlich noch ein Experimentalsystem war, ein Experimental-Raumfahrzeug, gleich beim ersten Flug bemannt flog. Das hat es bis dahin noch nicht gegeben. Das heißt, man ist also das Risiko eingegangen. Erster Flug, Leute rein, die sind gleich geflogen.
Hätte man das überhaupt unbemannt starten können?
Damals nicht. Damals war der Shuttle nicht dazu ausgelegt, ihn automatisch fliegen zu können, also unbemannt fliegen zu können. Später, sehr viel später, hatte man mal die Idee, den Shuttle auch unbemannt fliegen zu können. Es gab da auch mal ein entsprechendes Experiment, aber es ist nie dazu gekommen, dass man den Shuttle also hat unbemannt fliegen lassen.
Da war dann die Astronautengewerkschaft dagegen. Naja, ich meine, das ist natürlich auch immer so ein bisschen Teil des Zaubers. Man würde jetzt so, gerade wenn ich mir die USA mal vorstelle, mit ihrem leichten Hang zur Heldenverehrung, wenn dann auf einmal die Dinge ohne Menschen gehen, wie soll man denn da jetzt noch umarmen? Das ist natürlich auch etwas, was der ganzen Raumfahrt auch immer so ein bisschen Seele gegeben hat. Dass es da so mit realen Menschen auch zu tun hat. Und dass der Mensch selbst halt auch irgendwo hinkommt.
Natürlich, das ist richtig.
Na gut, die Zeit hat sich da so ein bisschen geändert. Ich denke, der Trend einerseits die Digitalisierung und die Datenübertragung ist weit fortgeschritten. Auf einmal musste man keine Filme mehr tauschen. Und ich das richtig sehe, hat sich dann auch relativ schnell dieser Hang zu Großsatelliten wieder zurückentwickelt. Weil man gesehen hat, das ist ja eigentlich viel günstiger und man hat weniger Verlust im Falle eines irgendwie gearteten Unfalls. Ich war, wenn man einfach einen kleinen Satelliten verliert, als wenn man gleich so einen Monster-Teil, wo man dann wieder zehn Jahre bauen muss, um die nächste Variante hochzubringen, sodass eigentlich der Shuttle so ein bisschen überdimensioniert erscheint.
Das war eher eine Zeit lang. Ich glaube, wir müssen noch mal da vielleicht, was du gerade gesagt hast, da noch mal ein bisschen zurückgehen. Von 1981, nachdem man also dann vier Erprobungsflüge gemacht hat, lief es eigentlich sehr gut bis 1985. Es waren also, ich glaube, über 20 Flüge, die gemacht worden sind in der Zeit. Man hatte viel zu tun, man hat Satelliten transportiert, sowohl kommerziell, wie auch institutionelle, also die von NASA gebaut worden sind. Dann hat man in 1985 es sogar geschafft, neun Shuttle im Jahr zu starten. Und das war eine Menge, das lief gut. Nur dann kam das Problem, dann kam 86, Februar 86, die große Katastrophe mit Challenger. Und das ist eben der Grund auch, warum danach dieser Katastrophe, wo wir ja sicherlich gleich nochmal vielleicht drauf kommen, danach hat sich das ganze Einsatzspektrum des Shuttles geändert. Man ging nicht mehr auf die kommerzielle Nutzung, sondern in der Zwischenzeit hatten sich ja auch die Wegwerfraketen in Anführungszeichen entwickelt. Ariane ist großgekommen, die Russen später dann auch, die Chinesen. Das heißt, man flog die Satelliten kommerziell jetzt auf den Wegwerfraketen, weil es einfach billiger war. Und man hatte ja auch eigentlich mal gedacht, dass man die große Shuttle-Ladebucht bei jedem Flug wirklich vollpacken konnte mit kommerziellen, vielleicht zwei, drei Satelliten sogar gleichzeitig mitnehmen können. Aber die kamen ja nicht so schnell nach. Das heißt, nur einen Shuttle zu fliegen mit einem Satelliten drin kommen, das hätte sich nicht gelohnt. Das hätte die Sache auch nicht finanziell getragen. Ja, dann kam der große Knall mit Challenger. Ich glaube, im Januar ist es gestartet. Es war kalt in Florida zu der Zeit, schon sehr lange. Drei, vier Wochen. Und jetzt kommen so ein paar Dinge, die auch so ein Blick auf die NASA, wie sie sich so im Laufe der Zeit entwickelt hat. Und auch die Firmen, die also zum Beispiel auch das System bestand, ja eben aus dem Orbiter, aus dem großen Tank und aus den beiden Feststoffraketen. Und die Firma, die eben die Feststoffraketen baute, Theocoll, die haben die NASA gewarnt, zu dem Zeitpunkt den Shuttle zu starten, Challenger. Denn diese Feststoffraketen bestehen aus mehreren Teilen und die sind verbunden durch überdimensionierte große Ohrringe, die also die Treibstoffsektionen untereinander abdichten. Und bei Theocoll hatte schon im Vorfeld, als bekannt war, wann der Starttermin von Challenger sein sollte, hat ein Techniker von Theocoll gewarnt und hat gesagt, er würde Challenger zu diesem Zeitpunkt nicht fliegen, es sei zu kalt und diese Ohrringe, diese Dichtungsringe, würden nur bis knapp über 0 Grad wirklich dicht sein. Es war so, dass auf dem Startgerüst am Tag, bevor gestartet wird, Eis zapfen waren. Es waren also plus 3, plus 4 Grad. Aber das ist vielleicht das, was auch die NASA damals übersehen hat, oder unter gewissem Druck stand. Man wollte also möglichst viel starten. Und die Startrate ging immer mehr, auch in den Jahren, vor das Sicherheitsrisiko und vor das Sicherheitsinteresse. Und man hatte auch in den vorherigen Flügen schon bis zu dem Zeitpunkt immer mal wieder Probleme gehabt, auch mit den Dichtungsringen. Man hat nicht drauf gehört, das Management, das NASA-Management, und das muss man sagen, das war der Fehler des NASA-Managements, hat Challenger gestartet mit dem schlimmen Ergebnis, dass Challenger nach 70 Sekunden in der Luft auseinandergebrochen ist, explodiert ist, weil eben ein Dichtungsring, ein O-Ring am rechten Booster undicht wurde, heiße Gase austraten, auf die Befestigung der Feststoffrakete an den Tank trafen und dort quasi ein Loch eingebrannt haben. Und dann ist das Ganze explodiert. Und damit war es erstmal Schluss mit dem Shuttle-Programm.
Bringt mich dazu, kurz auf die dritte Ausgabe von Raumzeit hinzuweisen, wo ich in Lampolshausen war und ein schönes Gespräch hatte über diese Raketenantriebe selbst, wo auch die ganze Kraft, die in so einer Feststoffrakete im Gespräch ganz gut rüberkam, wer das noch nicht gehört hat, sollte da vielleicht auch nochmal reinhören. Was passiert ist, ist klar, das Ding ist dann explodiert und ja, das war alles ein ganz großes Problem. Alle Astronauten sind gestorben und ja, ein Riesendesaster. Gar nicht mal nur für Space Shuttle-Missionen, sondern auch eben für alle anderen Missionen. Das hält ja dann diesen ganzen Betrieb eigentlich auch.
Natürlich. Und es war in der Hinsicht auch noch, also doch sehr, auch sehr schlimm für uns selbst, also für das Deutsche, für die deutschen Wissenschaftler, für die deutsche Raumfahrt-Community, denn es war Challenger. Und mit Challenger sind wir 1985 noch geflogen auf die Eins. Und deswegen betrifft das einen natürlich noch wesentlich mehr.
Findest du es emotional oder hat es auch technische Gründe?
Nein, sicher emotional. Ich meine, man baut ja auch zu, man kann sagen, was man will. Wer so ein System mal gesehen hat, aus der Nähe, nicht nur im Fernsehen oder so, und sieht so einen, sieht diesen 50 Meter hohen Koloss, dieses System da, der Mund geht nicht mehr zu. Also es ist wirklich wahr, man kann da schon eine emotionale Bindung aufbauen zu so einem System. Zu einer Maschine ist zwar vielleicht etwas lustig, aber wenn man die Leute dann selbst mal trifft, und ich hab häufig Leute getroffen während meiner Aufenthalt, drüben die mit dem Space Shuttle eben zu tun haben, die stehen alle voll hinter ihrem System. Und die waren alle mit Herzblut dabei. Man kann wirklich auch, wie man zu einem Auto, so eine emotionale Emotionalität aufbauen kann, kann man das auch zu so einem System.
Ja, ja, gar kein Zweifel. Da muss man sich nur anschauen, wie Käferfans so drauf sind. Da kann man das schnell hochrechnen auf so eine Raumfähre. Das bringt uns vielleicht mal ein bisschen mehr zur Technik selber. Also was macht den Shuttle eigentlich aus? Es gab ja nicht nur einen Space Shuttle, sondern es gab mehrere. Insgesamt gab es fünf. Und waren die denn identisch? Also waren das dieselben oder haben die sich noch unterschieden?
Die haben sich in gewisser Hinsicht unterschieden. Ich bin ja immer noch der Meinung, das ist auch die Meinung vieler anderer, die sagen, diese fünf Shuttle sind eigentlich alles Unikate. Man ist ja eigentlich nie in eine Serie, in eine richtige Serie reingekommen. Und deswegen gab es auch Unterschiede in den einzelnen Shuttlen. Discovery war zum Beispiel schwerer als alle anderen. Also drei bis vier Tonnen. Dann gab es zwei Shuttle, jetzt weiß ich nicht mehr genau, welche es waren. Damals hatte man ja auch gedacht, dass man, wenn zum Beispiel ein Satellit, wenn eine Stufe versagte des Satelliten, der ihn auf die richtige Bahn bringen könnte, dass man also so eine Stufe mit dem Shuttle hochbringt und quasi den Satelliten neu ausrüstet mit dieser Stufe, sodass er dann wieder auf die richtige Bahn angehoben werden kann. Deswegen gab es bei zwei Shuttlen in der Shuttle-Ladebucht Vorrichtungen, wo man so eine Vollgetankte Centaur-Oberstufe unterbringen konnte. Das kam aber nie zum Einsatz. Es ist nie zum Einsatz gekommen. Dann gab es zwei Shuttle. Die Shuttle haben ja nur eine begrenzte Aufenthaltsdauer an der Raumstation. Normalerweise versorgen sich die Shuttle ja selbst, sind ja autark. Das heißt, sie haben ihre eigene Energieversorgung, sie nehmen ihr eigenes Wasser mit, ihren eigenen Sauerstoff. Das heißt, es sind also auch eigentlich kleine Raumschiffe. So war es ja früher auch, als es die Raumstation noch nicht gab. Aber dann im Zusammenhang mit der Raumstation hat man zum Beispiel zwei Shuttle ausgerüstet, mit einem sogenannten Space Station to Shuttle Power Transformation System, Transfer System. Also ein System, wo man quasi das Space Shuttle an die Stromversorgung der Raumstation anschließen könnte.
Wer hat dann wen geladen?
Die Raumstation hat dem Shuttle den Strom geliefert. Denn die Raumstation hat ja ihre riesen Solar, ihre Solar Panel hat genug Energie gehabt und auch eben Strommöglichkeiten, um den Shuttle noch mit zu versorgen.
Warum hat man das gemacht, um die Aufenthaltsdauer zu verlängern?
Dann bis zu 30 Tagen hätte man dann also gut oben bleiben können. Das hat dann ja natürlich immer noch auch was damit zu tun. Die Systeme, die Ressourcen des Shuttles sind ja begrenzt. Man hatte die Brennstoffzellen. Jede Shuttle hat also drei Brennstoffzellen. Wasserstoff, Sauerstoff, Brennstoffzellen. Also die ganz normalen, die also heute auch zum Beispiel auf U-Booten eingesetzt werden. Die hatten die schon sehr früh, sehr zuverlässig bei denen über Wasserstoff und Sauerstoff also Strom erzeugt wird. So genau, ich bin nicht da der Riesentechniker. Jedenfalls die Stromerzeugung über diese Brennstoffzelle. Und die liefert wiederum dann noch als Endprodukt Wasser. Es kommt dabei Wasser raus.
Das ist quasi das Abgas.
Das Abgas. Und das waren immerhin 10 Liter pro Stunde. Und so haben die also ihren Wasservorrat auch ergänzt. Aber sie waren auch durchaus in der Lage im Gegenzug. Strom für Wasser. Der Raumstation auch noch zusätzliches Wasser zu liefern.
Eigentlich optimal, ne? Was vielleicht nochmal so kurz zum Aufbau ist.
Ja, okay.
Dass man das so ein bisschen klarer noch im Kopf hat. Also wir haben es ja schon angedeutet. Es gibt den Hauptteil, also die eigentliche Fähre oder der Transporter, wie auch man immer das Ding jetzt nennen möchte. Kennt man ja Delta-Flüge, also so diese spitzzulaufenden Flüge, mit denen man auch wieder landen konnte, die also auch Aerodynamik hatten, die man ja eigentlich so im Weltall so nicht braucht. Eine riesige Ladeklappe für die Nutzlast und davor so ein kleines Cockpit oder so. Das ist es wahrscheinlich gar nicht. Wie viele Astronauten konnten letztlich in die Shuttles?
Also es gab einen Flug sogar, wo acht Astronauten untergebracht waren. Normalerweise ist es so, dass vorne der vordere Teil vor der Ladebucht, also vor dem Hauptteil, besteht aus dem sogenannten Flugdeck. Dort sitzt vorne der Pilot und der Kommandant. Dann dahinter noch eine Reihe. Da sitzen dann noch zwei Astronauten. Und dann gibt es versetzt unten das sogenannte Mitteldeck. Und dort sind die anderen Sitze aufgebaut. Dort sitzen also noch drei, maximal auch vier Astronauten während des Starts und der Landung.
Also sieben oder acht.
Sieben oder acht, aber normalerweise ist man mit sieben Astronauten geflogen. Das ist die Standardbesatzung. Wenn der Shuttle oben war im Orbit, hat man dann eben sofort schnell die Ladebucht geöffnet. Das musste man, denn der Shuttle, dadurch, dass er ja seine eigene Energie erzeugt, seine eigene Lebensumgebung schafft, steht Wärme und diese Wärme muss abgeführt werden. Und mit geschlossenen Ladeklappen geht das nicht, mit der Ladebucht. Deswegen, sobald der Shuttle oben ist nach dem Start und der seinen Orbit erreicht hat, den er dann nachher auch braucht, um an die ISS anzudocken oder früher eben seinen Orbit, um eben seine Wissenschaft zu machen oder das, was er vorhatte, muss sofort, die werden die Ladeluken aufgeklappt und auf den Innenseiten der Ladeluke sind Radiatoren. Das sind also Radiatoren, sind Wärmetausch, wo also die Wärme, das Warme nach außen geht und abgeführt wird an den Weltraum.
Weil es ja keine Konvektion gibt. Die Wärme geht nicht einfach so nach oben.
Und das war also wirklich ein Abbruch, ein Abbruchsszenario. Wenn die Ladeklapp-Mos sich irgendeinem Grund nicht hätten öffnen lassen, das ist ja auch eine Mechanik, hätte die Mission abgebrochen werden müssen.
Muss man gleich wieder landen.
Weil sonst wäre das Ding einfach erhitzt.
Erhitzt, wäre erhitzt und wäre irgendwann ausgefallen, die Systeme, ganz klar. Gut, dann haben wir also das Mitteldeck und von da haben wir dann auch nochmal eine Luftschleuse. Denn der Shuttle war ja auch so ausgelegt und da kommen wir dann auch wieder zu Space Lab, dass man einen Tunnel hatte, also eine Luftschleuse, aus der man über einen Tunnel in das Space Lab konnte.
Also beziehungsweise generell erstmal in diesen Nutzlastbereich.
In diesen Nutzlastbereich konnte und zwar eben unter Druckverhältnissen. Unter normalen Druckverhältnissen. Das heißt, diese Luftschleuse war also da. Dann hatte man auch noch die Möglichkeit, in dem Mitteldeck zu schlafen. Man hatte also dort Schlafmöglichkeiten. Man hatte eine Toilette, also Hygieneeinrichtungen, wo man sich eben auch waschen konnte, ein bisschen sich sauber machen konnte und eben auch eine Toilette brauen. Das ist ganz klar, war ja immer, ist ja witzigerweise in den Medien immer auch ein Thema gewesen. Ich traue mich nicht zu fragen. Man hatte also im sogenannten Mitteldeck auch noch viele Einbauschränke, wo man also auch durchaus Experiment mitnehmen könnte. Also die in der Größe, die dort reinging. Und die Astronauten waren auch gleichzeitig immer die, die auch die Experiment mit durchführten. Gut, dann hinten, gehen wir weiter hinten, Antrieb des Shuttles. Hauptantrieb, drei große, drei großes.
Ist denn eigentlich in dieser Ladeluke irgendwas Besonderes oder ist das einfach nur leer?
Nein, es sind eine ganze Menge, ist natürlich eine ganze Menge an Anbringungsmöglichkeiten da, um verschiedene Nutzlasten dort zu befestigen. Und außerdem, was natürlich auch noch sehr gut war, oder was von Anfang an ja auch eingeplant war, der Shuttle besitzt auch einen Roboterarm. Das ist ein 15 Meter langes Gebilde, was also auf der einen Seite des Shuttles bei Geschlossenen in der Ladebucht an der Seite angeklemmt ist. Und sobald die Ladebucht auf ist, kann man mit dem Shuttle, und das ist das Gute eben, kann man eben Nutzlast zum Beispiel greifen, sie irgendwo hin transferieren an die ISS oder aber auch allein nur um zum Beispiel einen Satelliten, der nicht direkt aus der Ladebucht startet, dass man den also zum Beispiel raussetzt. Oder auch, es gab mal Systeme, die für eine Zeit lang aus der Shuttle-Ladebucht ausgesetzt wurden, dann ihre eigene Sache machten, das heißt dort dann unabhängig von der Störung durch Restbeschleunigung, die in so einem Shuttle herrschen, da wird gelaufen, da sind Maschinen. Wenn man also Experimente haben will, die nur eine ganz geringe Störbeschleunigung benötigen, um zum Beispiel Wachstumsvorgänge in Zellen und Pflanzen zu untersuchen. Daher benutzt man dann eben autonome Palettes, die man aussetzen kann mit einer eigenen Versorgung über Batterien und die dann entweder Wochen oder es gab ja eins, LDEV, die war ja fast über zwei Jahre im All, die dann nachher wieder eingefangen worden ist. Von einer nachfolgenden Mission dann wieder. Mit dem Kran. Mit dem Kran, mit diesem Roboterarm. Und dieser Roboterarm bekam dann ja gerade auch in der Verbindung mit dem Aufbau der ISS überhaupt seine Riesenaufgabe. Denn ohne das wär es gar nicht gegangen. Denn alle Teile der Raumstation, alle Infrastruktur-Teile, auch die Module, die dort oben zusammengesteckt sind, haben ja keine eigenen Antriebe. Das heißt, man musste sie also erstmal aus der Ladebuch des Shuttles heben. Dann auch, Raumstation war ja auch schon mal, glaube ich, ein Raum.
Ja, da haben wir schon drüber gesprochen.
Also Raumstation hatte ja auch ein Roboterarm-System, sodass also dieser Roboter von der Raumstation zusammen mit dem Roboterarm des Shuttles sehr stark interagierte. Das heißt, der eine nahm das Ding aus der Ladebuch und sagte, hier fang. Hier fang, zwar nicht so, aber fast, also wirklich. Und dann hat eben der Roboterarm vom Raumstation die Sachen übernommen und dann eben an die entsprechenden Stellen.
Amerikanische und kanadische Technologie sozusagen Hand in Hand.
Ja, das ist also die Robote, da haben also die Kanadier, das ist ihr Anteil an der Raumstation in Kanada. Und der sogenannte, wird ja auch genannt, Kanadarm, ist schon eine Riesensache. Und ja auch durchweg fehlerlos arbeitet das Ding dort oben. Also es ist wirklich toll. Also wie gesagt, an sich war die Ladebucht leer. Das war ja auch das Gute, man konnte also die vier Meter Durchmesser, die also diese Röhre, also diese Halbzylinder hatte, konnte man voll ausnutzen.
Und wie lang?
Ja ungefähr 16 Meter. Und ja 18, zwei Meter länger. Ich glaube, 18 Meter, also um die 18 Meter. Und da konnte man eben, wie konnte man voll ausnutzen, entweder mit Modulen, mit Paletten, mit Satelliten. Man hat aber auch zum Beispiel auf bestimmten Paletten, die also auch zum Teil fest eingebaut wurden, auch wenn Missionen waren, die nicht unbedingt die wissenschaftliche Art waren, hat man sogenannte Getaway-Special-Kanister gehabt, die hatten eine eigene Stromversorgung. Dort konnte man Experimente unterbringen, die autonom abliefen. Das war so eine Piggyback, so eine Nutzlast nebenbei, sodass man das auch immer ein bisschen mit verquicken konnte, Wissenschaft und auch...
Zum Füllen.
Zum Füllen, genau. Hauptsache voll. Der Shuttle hat ja einen eigenen Antrieb, im Gegensatz zum Beispiel zu Buran. Buran war ja diese Entwicklung der Russen.
Die ganz genauso aussahen.
Als wir das erste Mal Bilder gesehen haben, haben wir gesagt, die können ja wirklich gut abkupfern. Aber Buran war eben doch anders als der Space Shuttle. Da kann man vielleicht nachher nochmal kurz sagen. Space Shuttle hatte einen eigenen Antrieb. Hatte hinten drei große Haupttriebwerke, die über den großen Tank, der mit Wasserstoff und Sauerstoff gefüllt wird, angetrieben wurden. Es gab ja den ET-External Tank, also diese drei Haupttriebwerke, die wurden über diesen großen Tank gespeist. Und dann gab es noch zwei Triebwerke direkt daneben, auch hinten oberhalb der drei Triebwerksaustritte. Das waren die sogenannten OMS, Orbital Maneuvering Systems. Das waren Triebwerke, die man im Weltraum nutzte. Zum Beispiel um größere Lageänderungen zu machen des Shuttles. Aber wichtig waren sie vor allem auch vor dem Wiedereintritt. Und dann hatte man noch eine Unmenge über 40 an Lage-Regelungstriebwerken. Das sind kleine Triebwerke, die waren also sowohl vorne in der Nase untergebracht, in der Nasenkappe des Shuttles, wie auch hinten. Und die dienten also zum großen Teil, um kleine Lage-Regelungen des Shuttles zu machen. Also zum Beispiel, wenn der Shuttle sich dreht um die Achse, oder was dann auch beim Wiedereintritt ja vorkommt. Dazu braucht man dann diese Reaction Control Systems, also diese kleinen Lage-Regelungsdüsen.
Das dürfte insbesondere beim Zusammenbauen der ISS ganz hilfreich gewesen sein.
Nein, da waren die nicht wichtig. Die waren vorher beim Andocken noch wichtig. Aber der Shuttle war ja nachher fest angekoppelt an der Raumstation. Die haben also da keine...
Auch beim Zusammenbau......
der Raumstation.
Da muss ja erst mal ein erstes Modul irgendwo hingelegt werden.
Ja, klar, am Anfang war ja der russische Teil oben, das FGB.
Der ist von den Russen gestartet worden mit der Proton.
Das war ja dann der Teil, der die Raumstation auch bis heute noch, immer noch, wo auch Steuerungsdüsen sind. Die haben das System schon damals auch in ihrem Orbit und in ihrer Lage gehalten. Möglicherweise, ich muss sagen, das weiß ich nicht so hundertprozentig. Es mag sein, dass ganz am Anfang auch noch diese kleinen Düsen noch mitgeholfen haben. Aber nachher nicht mehr, denn der Shuttle war fest angekoppelt an die Raumstation und hat eigentlich alles das mitgemacht.
Okay, also die ganze Lage-Regelung ist eher dazu da, damit das Ding auch wieder zurückkehren kann.
Genau, genau, genau.
Was ja auch eine der Besonderheiten überhaupt des Space Shuttles ist. Es gibt ja nicht so viel, was überhaupt zurückkehren kann.
Also das war dann eben, das ist so im Groben und Ganzen der Shuttle-Aufbau. Er hatte eben auch natürlich ein Fahrwerk und aufgrund seiner Fähigkeiten, seiner einzigartigen Fähigkeiten, eben wieder Eintritt zu machen, hat er natürlich auch eine besondere Oberfläche, der Shuttle. Weil er hitzeresistent sein muss. Und er hat eben dann, sollen wir gleich hier auch darauf eingehen? Er hatte also seinen gesamten Rumpf, seinen gesamten Bauch unten drunter. Also wenn man von unten auf den Shuttle guckt, ist ja voll mit Hitzeschutzkacheln. Das waren früher mal über 30.000, aber das hat man dann in der Entwicklung auch. Das ist auch so eine Entwicklung. Die Shuttle flog schon und trotzdem hat man in der Probung die Kacheln weiterentwickelt. Das heißt, am Anfang klebten die nicht richtig. Die Kacheln, also die Hitzeschutzkacheln. Und dann passiert es, dass also nach so einem Erprobungsfluch da, gut, dass das nicht ganz hoch ging, dass dann bis zu 100 Kacheln abgefallen waren, als man hinterher guckte. Und man hat dann eben einen anderen Klebstoff gefunden. Aber es ist eben so, beim Wiedereintritt erfährt der Shuttle ja unterschiedliche Temperaturen. Das heißt, die Hitzeschutz-Kacheln, die untern am Bauch des Shuttles waren, das war also auch der größte Anteil, das waren Kacheln, die waren so ungefähr 12 Zentimeter im Durchmesser, so 6 Zentimeter stark, die bestanden aus Silizium, aus Siliziumdioxid, aber nur knapp 10 Prozent. Und alles andere war Luft. Und auf der Seite, die nach außen zeigte, war eine dunkle, feste Schicht, das nennt sich Bohrsilikat. Und ich habe selbst mal das Tolle, diese Kacheln kann man erhitzen, die nehmen also die Hitze auf und geben sie nicht weiter, also bis 1200, 1300 Grad Celsius. Diese Temperaturen bekommt also die Unterseite und die Nasenkappe vorne und die Flügelvorderkanten jeweils kriegen sogar bis 1600 Grad beim Wiedereintritt, kurzzeitig, über ein paar Minuten. Das machen dann immer, wenn man bei der NASA ist und sich solche Kacheln mal da im OPF, in der Orbital Processing Facility, das heißt da, wo die Orbiter nach dem Start und auch vor dem Start vorbereitet werden, bevor sie dann nachher in das VAB, in das Vertical Assessment Building, also in dieses Riesengebälde, was damals für die Saturn gebaut worden ist, wenn die also überführt werden. Da machen die gerne so mit dem Schweißbrenner und halten dann mal auf so eine Kachel drauf, die wird weiß glühend und die kann man in die Hand nehmen.
Während sie noch so heiß ist, kann man sie in die Hand nehmen.
Kann man sie in die Hand nehmen. Diese Kacheln haben die, weil sehr viel Luft ist, von der Rückseite in die Hand nehmen. Man kann sie so in die Hand nehmen, denn die nehmen die Hitze auf und geben sie nicht weiter. Das heißt, die Wärme wird in dieser Kachel gespeichert und kommt nicht raus. Wer das entwickelt hat, finde ich unheimlich toll. Jedenfalls, das klappt so.
Also es ist keine Hitzeabweisung, sondern eigentlich mehr so ein Hitzeverschlucker.
Hitzeverschlucker, ja, richtig.
Das heißt, beim Wiedereintritt, in dem Moment, wo eben die Atmosphäre dichter wird und das Shuttle doch mit einer enormen Geschwindigkeit, da gehen Erde segelt, durch die Reibung mit der Atmosphäre wird es halt heiß. Und diese Hitze verschwindet geradezu in dieser Außenhaut.
In diesen Kacheln, ja.
Und so kann dann diese kritische Phase, ich weiß nicht, wie lange dauert das, ein paar Minuten wahrscheinlich?
Das sind 8 Minuten, so was. Ja, man geht also ziemlich steil in die Atmosphäre rein. Das heißt, da wird dann auch noch alles, das macht, wird alles automatisch, da haben die Astronauten keinen Einfluss drauf. Die sind natürlich vor dem Wiedereintritt, gehen in ihre Druckanzüge rein, die sie nutzen. Ist ja nicht so, dass sie da so wie in einem Verkehrsflugzeug drin sitzen, sondern haben spezielle Druckanzüge, Anzüge für, gerade für diesen Fall, für Start und für Landung. Diese Druckanzüge haben auch nach Challenger hinten einen Fallschirm drauf und ein Überlebenspack, wo sogar ein kleines Schlauchboot drin ist. Das war vor Challenger nicht der Fall. Es gab keine großen Sicherheitseinrichtungen.
Wäre das bei der Challenger-Katastrophe geholfen?
Nein, gar nicht. Überhaupt nicht. Da hätte es nicht geholfen. Keine Chance? Nein. Und es hätte auch nicht geholfen. Gut, bei der Challenger, das war 70 Sekunden. Das ging so schnell. Und auch bei der Columbia konnte man auch nicht verhindern. Denn dieser Fehler, der auftrat, war, dass beim Start Schaumstoff des Außentanks abgeplatzt war und diese Flügelvorderkante getroffen hat, obwohl die durch ein Material, das nennt sich Kohlefaserverstärkte Kohlenstoff, das RCC Carbon, die eigentlich besonders fest und solche Unfälle vermeiden sollten. Aber man war damals noch nie, hat das nicht geglaubt, dass so etwas passiert und deswegen hat man dem auch keine große Bedeutung beigemessen, dass er in diese Flügelvorderkante ein Loch eingehauen hat.
Wir sind jetzt bei der zweiten Katastrophe der Columbia, die ja auseinandergebrochen ist beim Wiedereintritt. Der Grund war, beim Start ist Schaumstoff vom großen Tank. Schaumstoff klingt ja jetzt nicht gerade besonders bedrohlich.
Polyurethan ist das, dieser große Tank, der ist mit Schaumstoff isoliert, weil er eben sehr kalt, beim sehr kalten Sauerstoff und Wasserstoff minus 200 Grad in sich hat und um zu verhindern, dass die Kälte abfließt, ist dieser Tank isoliert mit Schaumstoff. Wenn es nur eine undurchbrochene Hülle gewesen wäre, wäre das wahrscheinlich gar nicht passiert, aber außen an diesem Tank sitzen natürlich auch Treibstoffleitungen. Das heißt, die Leitungen, wo der Sauerstoff und der Wasserstoff zum Orbiter geleitet wird. Die liegen außen fest in Klammern, die müssen auch isoliert sein, weil sich über diese Metallklammern auch Wärmeverlust gibt. Das kann man nicht maschinell machen. Die werden also mit Schaum manuell versehen. Das Problem ist, es ist ein Stück abgeplatzt von der Isolierung aus dem Bereich der iPods, das war wohl ein relativ großes Stück, und hat also ein Loch in diese linke Vorderfügelkante gehauen. Man ist hochgekommen, kein Problem.
Schaumstoff impliziert für mich ist weich. Aber das ist jetzt das falsche Bild, was ich gerade im Kopf habe.
Die Beschleunigung ist am Anfang so groß, dass auch Schaumstoff mit so einer Wucht auf die... Die Geschwindigkeit ist noch nicht angepasst. Das heißt, der Schaumstoff ist noch rot in sich, und die Rakete hat schon ballert vorbei, und dann passiert das. Nach ungefähr 60, 70 Sekunden ist das vorbei.
Und dann ist der Hitzeschild beschädigt worden?
Die Flügelvorderkanten sind ja verstärkt mit dem Carbon, mit dem Kohlefaser verstärkten Werkstoff, ist sehr spröde und fest und soll eben auch gerade solche kleinen Dinge eigentlich fernhalten, dass es nicht kaputt geht. Das hat aber eben dieses Loch da reingeschlagen. Das haben die natürlich bemerkt am Boden, haben die mir aber keine große Bedeutung beigemessen. Und dann ist man dort hochgeflogen.
Einfach, dass der Start von Kameras so überwacht wird?
Nee, das ist erst danach gekommen. Das war ja das Problem. Es ist jedenfalls bemerkt worden, dass irgendwas abgeflogen ist und auf den Orbiter getroffen ist. Es gab damals schon Kameras auf den Startgerüsten. Die gab es schon. Man hat bemerkt, dass da was passiert ist. Aber man hat das eben nicht die Tragweite ermessen können, weil man damals noch nicht so weit war. Ja, das hat sich dann ja eben gezeigt. Und dann ist eben dieses Schlimme passiert. Beim Wiedereintritt wird der Hitz so bis 1600 Grad. Und es entsteht dann heißes Plasma, wenn dieser Shuttle in die Atmosphäre eintritt. Und dieses heiße Plasma ist eben in dieses Loch eingedrungen. Und die Struktur im Inneren des Flügels ist Aluminium. Und das ist aufgeschmolzen. Und dadurch ist der linke Flügel desintegriert. Und dadurch wurde das gesamte Shuttle instabil und ist auseinandergebrochen.
Also der Hitzeschild selber war es gar nicht. Die eigentliche Kraftstruktur des Flügels wurde einfach an der entscheidenden Stelle eigentlich nur so punktuiert.
Aber nur eben weil das Loch hat sich da wohl auch noch vergrößern können. Und dann ist also dieses heiße Plasma da eingedrungen. Da ist ja um den Shuttle natürlich auch möglichst leicht zu bauen. Da ist dort eine Aluminiumstruktur drin. Die hält die Temperatur aber nicht aus. Danach gab es dann, wie auch nach der ersten, da haben wir zwar nicht drüber gesprochen, aber auch natürlich nach dem Challenger-Unfall, hatten wir ja eine riesen Kommission, die also den Unfall untersucht hat. Man hat damals ja auch dadurch Ergebnisse erzielt und den Shuttle auch verbessert. Man hat auch gemerkt, dass die Strukturen in der NASA zum Teil nicht so richtig miteinander funktionierten. Das heißt, es lief ja alles gut bis Challenger. Dann hat man so ein bisschen Schlendrian, kann man fast sagen, ist so eingezogen. Man hat vor allen Dingen immer relativ wenig auf die Ingenieure gehört, wenn es nicht ganz wesentliche Dinge waren, die also wirklich verhinderten, dass gestartet werden kann. Aber so kleine Dinge, die hat man dann auch in den Flügen bis 85. Da ist dann was kaputt gegangen und dann hat man eben hinterher gesagt, okay, Analyse, warum Analyse? Wir haben ja noch ein neues Teil, das gleiche neue Teil, aus dem anderen Shuttle, das nehmen wir daraus und packen das da wieder rein und hat sich überhaupt nicht wirklich intensiv darum gekümmert, warum ist das passiert? Es hat also immer Dinge gegeben und man muss sagen, glücklicherweise ist nicht mehr passiert. Insbesondere bis...
Aber immerhin so 130 Flüge?
Ja, jetzt mit Atlantis sind es dann 135 Flüge.
Das ist ja schon ganz ordentlich eigentlich.
Und eben nach dem Columbia-Unfall gab es ja wieder eine große Kommission. Und da hat man dann wiederum, es war wieder eine Zeitlage, es baut sich immer so auf, es läuft eine Zeitlage wunderschön. Und dann kommt der große Knall. Und nach Columbia hat man dann eben, was man gemacht hat, man hat den Tank überarbeitet, die Isolierung, die Schaumstoffisolierung hat also andere, auch andere Klammern gemacht, hat versucht, das anders zu beschäumen. Man hat vor allen Dingen, man hat überall jetzt auch auf das System Kameras gebaut, sowohl auf den Tank, auf den großen Außentank, auch auf die Feststoffraketen an den Seiten sogar, um den Startvorgang genau zu dokumentieren, um hinterher die Möglichkeit zu haben, zu reagieren, wenn der Shuttle oben ist. Denn hoch kommt er meist, nur was passiert, wenn man runterkommt. Und dann hat man zum Beispiel auch, dadurch, dass man die Erfahrung hatte, dass auch Hitzeschutzkacheln nach jedem Start auch beschädigt waren, hat man sogar nach Kolumbia ein Reparaturkit entwickelt. Sowieso wie beim Fahrrad hat man da eben so ein Reparaturkit für Kacheln. Das sind auch dann auf der Erde ausprobiert worden und die waren nach Kolumbia, nach Wiederaufnahme der Flüge in 2005 mit der Discovery, war so ein Reparaturkit immer an Bord.
Das ist auch mal verwendet worden?
Es ist nur im Falle eines Experimentes mal oben verwendet worden. Das ist nicht... Nein, ich glaube...
Weil keine Kacheln verloren gegangen sind oder...
Ja, weil keine Kacheln verloren gegangen sind. Die konnten auch... Man hat es aber immer dabei gehabt. Viel wichtiger war, dass man eine viel stärkere Kontrolle über den Hitzeschutzschild des Shuttles nach Columbia hat als vorher. Man hat nämlich den Shuttle, bevor er an die... Erst mal, als wenn er oben ist, der Shuttle gestartet ist, dann oben im Orbit ist und dann erst mal autonom fliegt, hat man ihn erst mal mit seinem eigenen Roboterarm. Der hat vorne ein System von Kameras bekommen. Der Arm. Der Roboterarm des Shuttles. Und dann haben die dort oben erst mal geguckt, mit ihrem eigenen Roboterarm, sind die ihre Flügel abgefahren, geguckt. Das geht über Laser, über X-Ray. Und man hat diese Daten dann runtergeschickt an die Ingenieure. Und die haben geguckt, ist irgendwas. Und dann nach ein, zwei Tagen kam dann die Meldung, kommt dann über die Meldung auch, alles okay, prima. Aber man konnte natürlich nicht überall unten drunter gucken. So groß war der Shuttlearm nicht. Dann hat man ein neues Manöver eingeführt, das sogenannte RPM, Rendezvous Pitch Maneuver. Das heißt, der Shuttle ist unter die Raumstation geflogen, hat dann einen Backflip, eine Rolle rückwärts, quasi um die Längsachse unter der Raumstation gemacht. In einer Entfernung von 300 Metern hat er also langsam unter der Raumstation in gleicher Geschwindigkeit eine Rückwärtsrolle um die Längsachse gemacht. In der Zeit haben oben die Astronauten aus dem Fenster die Unterfläche des Shuttles fotografiert mit hochauflösenden Kameras und hat dann auch die Bilder zur Erde geschickt. Die wurden dann unten auf dem Boden analysiert.
Das waren rein optische Kameras, keine Brücken.
Nein, das waren optische Kameras. Das haben die dann mit ihren Vergrößerungen die Möglichkeiten, die sie sekundär vergrößern, und alles, was sie haben, hat man das dann überprüft. Dann kriegt der Shuttle nachher das Go.
Der muss dann erst mal unter den Scanner. Dann wird geguckt, ob er noch alle Kacheln im Schrank hat.
Das war die große Erfahrung aus dem Columbia-Unfall. Das hat hinterher sehr viel Sicherheit gegeben. Auch eine subjektive Sicherheit. Objektiv natürlich auch, wenn man weiß, da ist etwas, was uns nicht unbedingt dort oben hält oder uns verhindert, wieder zurückzukommen. Denn das ist natürlich auch ein Riesenproblem. Da sind ja auch Möglichkeiten entwickelt worden nach Columbia, dass man dann sagte, wir brauchen noch parallel zu dem Shuttle, der gerade startet, ein weiteres Shuttle, was in der Lage ist, innerhalb kurzer Zeit als Rettungsmission zu starten, um ein Shuttle, was aufgrund von defekten Kacheln, die einen Wiedereintritt unmöglich machen, abholen kann.
Zumindest den Wiedereintritt so als so gefährdet erscheinen lassen, dass man lieber erstmal die Astronauten holt.
Erstmal die Astronauten holen. Es wäre dann eben, den würde man dann entsorgen.
Keine Möglichkeit, den zurückzuholen.
Nein, die Möglichkeit ist mal überlegt worden, einen Shuttle mal automatisch durch.
Die Astronauten können eh nicht eingreifen beim Rückflug. Dann könnte man ja sozusagen auch ohne Astronauten landen. Oder geht die Landung dann selbst nicht?
Die Landung nicht. Der Shuttle konnte nicht automatisch landen. Das heißt, ab einer bestimmten Entfernung, 20 Minuten vorher, bevor er gelandet wird, übernimmt er. Dann fliegt der Shuttle ja nicht mehr wie ein Raum. Dann ist er wieder aerodynamisch. Dann fliegt er wie ein Delta-Flügler zum Flugzeug, zum Segelflugzeug. Er hat ja keinen Antrieb mehr. Er hat dann eine Chance zu landen, die haben sie auch immer genutzt. Ich bin immer maßlos begeistert, wenn ich diese Shuttle-Landungen sehe. Jeder, der mit einem normalen Verkehrsflugzeug landet, sieht, wie ein Shuttle ohne Antrieb mit einer anderthalbmal höheren Geschwindigkeit als ein normaler Verkehrsflieger landet. Mit über 340 Stundenkilometern setzt er auf. Und wie sicher die aufsetzen und wie butterweich das geht, das sind schon die Astronauten, die haben schon eine fantastische Ausbildung. Das sind auch eben alles begnadete Flieger und fliegen auch alle gern.
Die Motivation der Astronauten, die kann man kaum infrage stellen. Ich hatte ja hier auch vor einiger Zeit ein schönes Gespräch mit der Astronautin Christoph Oretti aus dem neuen ESA-Team, der noch nicht geflogen ist, aber von ihrer Ausbildung berichtet hat und auch ihrer Vorbildung. Das merkt man eigentlich in jeder Minute, wie da die Motivation gerade aus allen Poren herausgekrochen kommt. Kein Wunder, dass das Team in solchen Momenten immer in der Lage ist, Herr der Lage zu bleiben, so ist die Technik den erlaubt. Jetzt können wir vielleicht noch mal ein bisschen auf diese Nutzung zurückkommen, was wir anfangs angesprochen haben. Shuttle war am Anfang, das fand ich ganz interessant. Die ursprüngliche Vision war tatsächlich so dieses Raumstation. Eigentlich sind die Amerikaner nicht zu halten gewesen. Jetzt haben wir den Mond und dann haben sie noch mal ihre Science-Fiction-Bücher aufgeklappt und durchgelesen, was als nächstes kommt. Dann stand da drin, Raumstation braucht man auch. Also wollen wir jetzt auch eine bauen. Dann brauchen wir jetzt erst mal etwas, womit man das bauen kann. Das war dann eigentlich das Shuttle. Große Ladeluke. Ich kann mir gar nicht so richtig vorstellen, dass man wirklich zu dem Zeitpunkt diesen Aspekt wissenschaftliche Forschung ausgeklammert hat. Es war schon mit angedacht, dass man da auch mal ein Labor reinbauen kann.
Ja, es war eben so, dass die Amerikaner, also das Post-Apollo-Programm, auch schon recht früh die Europäer gefragt haben, ob sie sich an diesem Programm beteiligen. Und dann hat sich eben Europa entschieden, dieses sogenannte SortiLab, also dieses Labor beizustellen. Das heißt, das haben sie nicht nur beigestellt, sondern die Amerikaner waren also da begeistert von. Denn das war auch für sie die Möglichkeit, Wissenschaft in großem Rahmen zu machen. Es war dann eben so, dass Europa, auch unter Führung Deutschlands, Erno war das damals, Frau Wehfocka Erner, Erno dieses Spacelab entwickelt hat und an die Amerikaner verschenkt hat.
Verschenkt?
Zwei Spacelabs sind an die Amerikaner geschenkt. Natürlich gegen Leistung. Das ist schon das, was man früher auch, was man später auch immer wieder gemacht hat, dass man keinen Cash zahlt, sondern man...
Man leistet seinen Beitrag zum Mission.
Man leistet seinen Beitrag und bekommt was dafür. Und das Spacelab war eben so, Europa hat gebaut, Amerika hat den Betrieb übernommen. Das, was dafür notwendig ist, um das Ding nach oben zu bringen.
So wie wir jetzt zum Beispiel auch beim SOFIA-Teleskop ähnliche Kooperationen haben. Beziehungsweise auch bei der ISS mit Kolumbus etc.
Die sogenannten BATA, diese immer BATA-Agreements, wie sie heißen, dieser Tauschhandel. Man vermeidet überall in den großen Programmen, selbst auch in den großen ISS-Programmen, Cash zu zahlen, sondern eben tauscht...
Bei Geld ist ja auch sehr flüchtig.
Also wie gesagt, dann hat man eben... Europa ist eigentlich sehr früh schon gefragt worden, ob sie mitmachen, haben dann Space Lab entwickelt. Und Space Lab ist lange geflogen, 1983 der erste Flug.
Also wer hat Space Lab konkret jetzt entwickelt?
Entwickelt hat es ein konsortium unter deutscher Führung, europäisches Konsortium. Da waren die Italiener beschäftigt, die Holländer waren beschäftigt.
Es war aber kein ESA-Programm?
Nein, doch, es war schon ESRO damals die Vorläufer. Also es war schon ein europäischer Beitrag. Nur wir haben ihn nachher eben zweimal sehr national genutzen können mit der D1 und der D2 Mission. Wir sind ja nie dazu gekommen. Es war mal dann in der Planung vielleicht auch noch mehrere Space Lab-Missionen zu machen. Vielleicht dann auch im europäischen Level. Sogenannte E-Missionen waren mal angedacht. Europäische Space Lab-Missionen. Aber das hat dann...
Challenger Katastrophe hat das dann unter anderem.
Und ich meine...
Also es hätte auch so ein Space Lab E1 dann gegeben.
Hätte geben können, aber auch wir Deutsche waren ja so vermessen. Ich war ja nun an beiden auch beteiligt. Wir hatten eigentlich gedacht, wir brauchen Kontinuität. Und man kann zwar einmal in acht oder zehn Tagen eine Menge an Experimenten machen. Unterschiedlich aber gerade bei Experimenten steht natürlich nicht nur die Qualität, sondern auch die Quantität. Dass man also viele Versuche macht. Aber da hat der Geldgeber nachher auch nicht mehr mitgespielt. Das war einfach zu teuer. Wir konnten es uns nicht mehr leisten. Die 2 hat im Endeffekt 900 Millionen DM gekostet. Das war eine stolze Summe zur damaligen Seite. Wir haben aber eben auch sehr gute Ergebnisse gehabt, aber es ist eben nicht weitergegangen. Space Lab ist dann ja noch bis 1998 geflogen. Auch in unterschiedlichen Missionen. Zu erwähnen ist 1983 die erste Space Lab-Mission, die dann quasi nur genutzt worden ist, um System Shuttle und System Space Lab zu testen. Aber es war ein First. Der erste ausländische Astronaut, der auf einem Shuttle mitgeflogen ist, war ein deutscher Ulf Merbold. Und der hat natürlich auch schon ein paar Experimente mit da oben gehabt. Und das war also schon was. Das war schon was. Und dann sind ja eben bei D1, ist ja dann Fura Messerschmidt mitgeflogen und bei D2 dann eben Walter und Schlegel. Wobei dann ja Schlegel auch später dann noch die Möglichkeit hatte, auf der Raumstation Columbus mit nach oben zu bringen. Also dann, 1998 war dann Schluss mit Space Lab. Und als letzte Mission war dann quasi Neuro Lab. Das war also eine wissenschaftliche Mission, die sich also mit medizinischen Experimenten beschäftigt hat. Aber es war eben auch natürlich einen gewissen Sinn, hat das gemacht, denn ab 1998 wurde die Raumstation aufgebaut. Und die Raumstation ist also dann, die Nutzung, die wissenschaftliche Nutzung ist dann verstärkt immer mehr auf die ISS übergegangen.
Die Space Lab Mission war ja sozusagen, da war dann, das Raumlabor hat den kompletten Raum des Space Shuttle gefüllt?
Nein, das Space Lab war durchaus auch ein System, was modular ausgelegt war. Es gab also, das Space Lab hatte ja einen, es gab einen langen Tunnel, einen kurzen Tunnel. Und deswegen war neben dem Space Lab auch noch die Möglichkeit, ist auch noch eine Palette entwickelt worden für Experimente, die unter Raumbedingungen stattfinden sollten. Und aufgrund des Schwerpunkts, die das ganze System Shuttle hat, musste das Space Lab, wenn es geflogen ist, immer ganz hinten, ganz hinten in der Ladebrucht sein. Das heißt, wenn man die Bilder sieht, die man von der D-2-Mission und aus dem Shuttle sieht, die also Astronauten aus dem Flug der Kinder, daraus gibt es ja Fenster, da wurde dann auch der Roboterarm von da aus bedient. Und dann sieht man also ganz weit hinten, sieht man also auf den Konus, auf das Ende vom Space Lab, vom Raumlabor. Und davor war also der Tunnel.
Und das war dann die Hälfte der Fläche, oder was?
Ja, der Space Lab war sieben Meter.
Aber die Mission war eigentlich voll auf das Space Lab hin ausgerichtet. Es gab jetzt nicht noch einen Satelliten, der noch mit rausgeworfen wurde.
Man hat, glaube ich, auch schon mal noch so BiPACs gehabt, so kleine Sachen ausgesetzt. Kleinkram. Gerade die Palette, die ist sogar noch sehr viel länger als Space Lab geflogen, weil diese Palette hatte wirklich, die war sehr...
Die ist später wieder eingefangen worden.
Nein, die Palette, die zum System Space Lab dazugehörte, die hat die NASA noch, ich glaube, bis 2010 geflogen.
Also die ist immer wieder mit hoch?
Die ist immer wieder mit hoch. Da waren eben entsprechende Experimente, Ersatzteile festgemacht, die man auf so eine Palette draufbringen konnte. Also das war also, das Space Lab-System in sich war also sehr, sehr erfolgreich.
Gab es denn noch ein anderes Laborsystem, außer dem Space Lab, was dann im Shuttle geflogen ist?
Ja, es gab dann nach Space Lab, kam dann ab 1993 das Space Hab. Space Hab war in der Hinsicht noch interessanter, weil es eben auch Fracht und Cargo fliegen konnte. Das war also schon so ein Frachtmodul.
Wer hat das gebaut?
Das haben die Amerikaner gebaut, Space Hab. Das ist so eine Firma, die heißt so. Die war auch im Coco Beach, Kennedy Space war die da. Die hat sich da eingebracht und hat also auch das Space Hab. Da gab es also eine Doppelversion, doppellanges, kurzes Kleid. War sehr flexibel. Die ist also auch bis 2007 geflogen, Space Hab. Space Hab konnte eben auch Fracht mit hochnehmen, richtig kräftig. Space Hab war ein Labor, ein Raumlabor. Da waren eben an der Seite, an den Seiten, wenn man mal sagt, links und rechts unter Erdbedingungen gesehen, waren links und rechts die Schränke, in denen die Experimente gemacht worden sind. Im Boden unten waren die ganzen Systeme, die notwendig waren, um Space Lab zu betreiben. Und oben war mal angedacht die Möglichkeit für ein Fenster. Aus Sicherheitsgründen ist das nie gebaut worden. Aber Space Lab war dann quasi das Modul, was bis 2003 geflogen ist. Und dann gab es ja die Entwicklung des MPLM, Multipurpose Logistic Module, was bilateral zwischen den Italienern und den Amerikanern gebaut worden ist. Und MPLM ist ja danach geflogen. Da gab es ja Leonardo und Raffaello. Das ist auch ein Labor, ein Logistics-Modul, ein Fracht-Modul.
Was ist ein Fracht-Modul?
Das ist auch ein Zylinder. Man hat also aufgebaut, auch auf Spacelab damals. Die Struktur hatte damals nämlich auch eine italienische Firma gebaut. Dieses MPLM konnte kräftig Fracht für die Raumstation nach oben bringen.
Ah, als Versorgungstransporter.
Und was es eben konnte, ja, es ist aber passiv. Es ist eben mit dem Shuttle hochgeflogen worden.
Aber wir reden jetzt schon von der Zeit, wo es dann die ISS gab und wo der Shuttle vor allem als Versorgungsfahrzeug für die ISS eingesetzt wurde.
Weil sie sagten, was noch transportiert worden ist. Weil es auch ein Modul war, was auch da dort reinpasste. Aber was eben den Vorteil hatte, man konnte es eben auch rausnehmen und andocken und dort wurde es dann entladen und hinterher dann wieder beladen und man konnte es wieder mit runternehmen.
Das ist auch so ein bisschen so ein Vorläufer vom ATV, das wir hier neulich schon besprochen haben.
Nur ATV kommt leider nicht zurück.
Ja, aber kommt immerhin alleine hin.
Hinten kommt alleine hin, das ist richtig.
Ja genau, darauf wollte ich jetzt auch nochmal darauf eingehen. Das Besondere ist ja, diese Space Lab sind ja dann auch alle wieder mit gelandet. Das heißt, da ist dann nichts verglüht.
Nein.
Man hat eigentlich die ganze Technik auch wieder zurückbekommen.
Genau, genau, genau.
Mit den Ergebnissen etc. Heißt das dann für D2 dann eigentlich, also handelt es sich um dasselbe Space Lab? Hat man dieselbe Struktur genommen oder ist das alles komplett neu entwickelt worden?
Nee, Space Lab war, nee, nee, das war das Space Lab, was man eben dann entsprechend für die speziellen Missionen, die D1, D2 ausgerüstet hat.
Okay, also es ist dasselbe Space Lab, was wieder mit hochgegangen ist.
Es ist dasselbe Space Lab, ja.
Da weiß man ja immer nicht, wenn man so in der Raumfahrt, da wird ja auch immer gerne wieder neu gebaut.
Und das Gute, weil eben alles das, was man dort oben gemacht hat, kriegt man eins zu eins auch wieder runter. Auch an Experimenten, was ja heute eben nicht der Fall ist. Oder jetzt bald nicht mehr der Fall ist.
Das ist ja eigentlich, das ist ja eigentlich eine tolle Sache, wenn ich das mal so sage. Und das fällt ja jetzt weg.
Ja, und das ist eben die Idee jetzt, nachdem der Shuttle, jetzt wo der Shuttle weg ist, fallen wir erstmal in ein tiefes Loch. Ich meine einerseits, ohne Shuttle wäre die Raumstation nicht denkbar. Die Raumstation ist jetzt aufgebaut, ist fertig. Die letzten Shuttle-Flühe sind wirklich bis auf den Rand, ist die Ladebucht vollgepackt worden, mit systemkritischen Ersatzteilen für die Raumstation. Teile, wo man also auch unten das Management gesagt hat, die könnten in der Laufzeit bis 2020, die ja verlängert worden ist, bis 2020 für die Raumstation erstmal, die können in der Zeit möglicherweise ausfallen. Also schaffen wir so viel an Ersatzteilen hoch, wie wir kriegen können und die letzten Shuttle-Missionen, die waren vollgepackt mit Ersatzteilen. Ja, und es ist ja auch alles von 2005 an, kann man ja sagen, nach Return to Flight mit der Discovery, ist es ja eigentlich gut bis sehr gut gelaufen mit den Shuttle-Flügen. Na gut, man hatte immer natürlich…
Was habe ich nicht verstanden, nach Return to Flight mit der Discovery?
Ja, nach dem Unfall der Columbia 2003 ist ja das Programm wieder ausgesetzt worden, wie es auch nach dem…
Also nach Wiederaufnahme des Programms.
Nach Wiederaufnahme des Programms 2005, das war dann wieder die Discovery. Und ja, da ist alles bestens gelaufen, aber man war eben sensibilisiert seit Columbia. Man hat den Shuttle immer sehr gut, sehr gut untersucht, nachdem er gestartet worden ist. Man hat auch bevor er gestartet wurde auf jede, jede Kleinigkeit geachtet. Und es gab ja Dinge, wo dann wirklich auch in den Management-Teams die Frage war, müssen wir deswegen jetzt auf den Start verzichten? Untersuchen wir das erstmal oder starten wir? Man hat sich immer für die sichere Variante entschieden jetzt. Man ist vorsichtig geworden.
Aber es ist wahrscheinlich auch alles viel teurer geworden.
Ist viel teurer geworden. Und mittlerweile machen wir mal fort, was das alles so kosten sollte. Man ist ja mal davon ausgegangen, dass man gesagt hat, eine Shuttle-Pilot, insbesondere für die kommerzielle Nutzung, hat man mal gesagt, wenn das gut läuft kommerziell, wir kriegen viele Satelliten, sollte das Kilogramm 200 Dollar kosten. Kilogramm Nutzlast. Das ging dann hoch im Endeffekt bis auf 16.000 Dollar pro Kilogramm. Die Staats, diese doch utopischen Überlegungen, bis zu 60 Staats im Jahr zu haben, die ja dann immer reduziert sind. Und wenn wir heute 5, 6, 7 im Jahr haben, wir hatten 1985 mal 9, hatten auch in den 90er Jahren mal durchaus immer, 5 war eigentlich immer mal so ein guter Schnitt. Da hat man dann doch gesagt, okay, wir müssen eben vorsichtig sein und wir passen auf, dass da nichts mehr passiert. Das hat die Kosten in die Höhe getragen. Und man geht heute davon aus, dass eine Shuttle-Mission, also Start, Betrieb, bis zum Ende wieder runter, fast eine Milliarde kostet. Früher, was so in der Presse herumschwirrst, sind immer so die 500 Millionen für so einen Start. Aber eine komplette Shuttle-Mission liegt so heute in dem Dreh so knapp unter einer Milliarde.
Das ist eine Menge Holz. Da fragt man sich natürlich auch immer wieder sofort, wie kann sich das überhaupt rechnen für alle Beteiligten? Wie kann man da den Erfolg dann überhaupt noch quantifizieren?
Ich glaube, das ist wieder diese philosophische Frage. Bei der nicht bemannten Raubfahrt stellt man die sich nicht. Das ist klar. Das ist kommerziell. Da gehen Satelliten hoch, die bringen was. Da hat man ein Ergebnis, das versteht jeder. Wetter-Satelliten, Kommunikations-Satelliten, all das. Das kennt jeder, aber bei der bemannten Raumfahrt hatten wir ständig die Diskussion, eigentlich von Beginn an, Kosten, Nutzen, warum überhaupt da hoch. Ich glaube, es ist immer das, was die Astronauten sagen und was ich von meiner Seite her immer sage. Und auch so, na, so kann man bemannte Raumfahrt durchaus auch sehen. Der Mensch ist neugierig. Er ist immer neugierig und er wird neugierig bleiben. Und ich fand es so schön, es gab mal ein Bild, da sah man im Hintergrund, das hat die NASA mal verbreitet, da sah man im Hintergrund das Kennedy Space Center, die ganzen Startanrichtungen und vorne auf dem Wasser sehr schön rein kopiert die drei Schiffe von Columbus.
Als Vergleich.
Als Vergleich und auch ohne Columbus, der auch ins Fremde gefahren ist und wusste auch nicht, wo es hingeht. Ich glaube, der Mensch entwickelt sich weiter und ist neugierig. Wenn er nicht mehr neugierig wäre, dann wäre es schlimm für uns.
Ich habe auch nicht die Befürchtung, dass das nicht mehr weitergeht. Ich habe auch das Gefühl, das braucht die Menschheit. Hätte es jetzt das alles nicht gegeben, hätte es wahrscheinlich viele Erkenntnisse nicht gegeben, die diese ganze kommerzielle Raumfahrt möglich machen.
Richtig. Natürlich. Im Rahmen dieser Raumfahrtentwicklung ist es die Miniaturisierung der Geräte, die es möglich gemacht haben, dass man so etwas überhaupt einbaut. Denn jedes Kilo zählt ja in der Raumfahrt bei den Trägern. Je leichter, desto besser ist es. Ich meine, es gibt immer Entwicklungen, die uns auch weitergebracht haben, dann auch hier unten auf der Erde. Aber man kann nicht nur alles daran messen. Insbesondere nicht gerade auch, was Raumstation anbelangt. Oder auch das, was damals bei Space Lab gemacht worden ist. Auch von unseren deutschen Experimentatoren. Es sind zum Großteil Grundlagenforschung, die dann möglicherweise im Laufe der Jahre später mal eine Anwendung finden. Es gibt ja diese berühmten Beispiele, zum Beispiel dieses Augendruck-Inndruck-Messgerät, was ja für den Einsatz im Raum entwickelt worden ist. Was hier unten jetzt verkauft wird. Man hat ja festgestellt, dass Raumfahrt, Raumflug die Muskelmasse reduziert und auch den Knochen reduziert, wenn man bei Langzeitaufenthalten. Das ist zwar reversibel, wenn man wieder zurückkommt, aber es gibt dann eben Experimente, wo man dann vielleicht sogar Schlüsse ziehen kann auf der Erde. Wie sieht es mit Osteoporose aus? Gibt es eine Möglichkeit, dass man da einsteigen kann, warum entwickelt sich der Knochen in Schwerelosigkeit oben dort zurück bei den Astronauten? Was ja auch immer dazu führt, dass der Astronaut jeden Tag mindestens 90 Minuten trainieren muss.
Und sogar das reicht nicht.
Und das reicht schon nicht. Und es gibt ja schon seit langer, langer Zeit, hat man das erkannt und hat immer schon von Anfang an auch Geräte mit hochgebracht, Ergometer, Drehträder, Laufbänder, Expander, um den Astronauten eine Möglichkeit zu schaffen, sich körperlich fit zu halten. Und selbst das reicht nicht. Und deswegen sind solche Ideen, bemannt zum Mars zu fliegen, über so eine lange Zeit, muss man noch eine Menge tun, um herauszubekommen, wie man eben die Möglichkeit, dass sich das nicht potenziert, diese medizinischen Dinge, ob das nicht nachher schädigend wirkt auf den Astronauten. Also gerade auch in der Medizin ist eine ganze Menge dort oben entwickelt worden, Materialien, neue. Also es kommt immer was, aber man kann, glaube ich, unter Kosten nutzen, kann man diese Dinge alle nicht...
Bis zu diesem klassischen Traum der Science Fiction, dass man Monate und Jahre lang auf Raumschiffen durchs Weltall gleitet und sich ganz normal weiterentwickelt. Da ist doch noch ein weiter Weg zu gehen. Was bedeutet denn jetzt das Ende des Shuttle-Programms, außer dass man jetzt das Versorgungsfahrzeug für die ISS verliert?
Ja, es bedeutet erstmal für die Amerikaner, dass sie in ein tiefes Loch fallen, in ein programmatisches tiefes Loch. Und das haben sie selbst zum großen Teil mit zu verschulden. Sie haben es eigentlich versäumt, sich rechtzeitig um ein Nachfolgesystem zu kümmern.
Weil sie zu spät eingesehen haben, dass die Probleme nicht zu bewältigen sind?
Nein, das hat durchaus auch finanzielle Probleme gehabt. Der NASA geht es nur auch nicht so gut, auch finanziell gesehen. Und sagen wir mal, ein Riesenprogramm, wie das Shuttle-Programm, noch voll durchzufinanzieren und weiter zu fliegen, gleichzeitig aber ein neues Programm, was durchaus auch, man hat sich ja verabschiedet von dem, in Amerika verabschiedet von diesem System, der Wiedereintrittsfahrzeuge, sondern geht ja wieder zurück auf das alte Apollo-Prinzip. Man hat eine Rakete, man setzt eine Kapsel obendrauf und man startet das eben.
So wie die Europäer ja in der Zwischenzeit sehr erfolgreich gewesen sind.
Genau, aber insgesamt auch. Ich meine auch, wie es die Russen heute schon immer gemacht haben, mit ihren Sojuskapseln. Es ist ein einfaches System und vor allen Dingen ist es für die Astronauten sicherer. Früher hieß es immer, das Shuttle sei eine eierlegende Wollmilchsau. Wer als Physiker oder wer auch als Ingenieur oder Techniker kommt eigentlich auf eine Idee, ein Shuttle, ein System mit Menschen besetzt auf einen Sauerstoff- und Wasserstoff gefüllten Tank zu setzen. Auf die Breitseite, auf die Längsseite. Wenn da was passiert, und zumal hat sich ja ergeben, und das muss man bei der NASA auch sagen, Kostengründe haben verhindert, dass für das Shuttle-System ein Rettungssystem für die Astronauten entwickelt worden ist. Das, was eigentlich mal geplant war, das ganze Cockpit vorne abspringen zu können, ist aus Kostengründen vergessen worden. Es gibt zwar die Möglichkeit, wenn vor dem Start was passiert, gibt es ja die sogenannte Seilbahn, die vom Startgerüst aus oben an Seilen die Astronauten innerhalb kurzer Zeit unten in zwei Bunker reinfährt. Das heißt also, wenn man...
Das gibt es.
Das gibt es schon immer. Das ist noch nie benutzt worden. Es wird nur immer getestet. Eine Seilbahn. Die oben an dem Gerüst, da wo auch die in der Nähe die Astronauten aussteigen würden, wenn irgendwas wäre. Aus dem... Kann man in diese Seilbahn... Das ist also ein Korb, so ein Drahtseilkorb, der hängt mit Rädern an so einem Seil. Da springen die Astronauten rein. Das Ding wird oben losgekappt und rast dann runter und rast in einen Tunnel rein. Also auch wenn es dann explodieren würde, wären sie unten in dem Tunnel sicher. In dem Bunker.
Sicherer als...
Sicherer, ist nie benutzt worden, wird aber immer zu Trainingszwecken auf dem Lauf gehalten. Dann gab es mal die Überlegung, an der Seite auch ein aufsprengbares Türchen zu haben, quasi eine Tür, aus der man... Aber das geht nur, wenn der Shuttle schon ein bestimmtes Manöver fliegt. Deswegen gibt es ja jetzt auch nach dem Unglück mit der Challenger, dass jeder Astronaut auch einen Fallschirm hat, das Rausspringen aus dem Shuttle, um mit dem Fallschirm abzuführen. Das geht aber nur in einem ganz bestimmten, engen Rahmen. Das heißt, wenn der Shuttle in einer stabilen Fluglage ist, aus der die Astronauten noch rauskönnen.
Also nach dem Wiedereintritt?
Nein, vor dem Wiedereintritt gar nicht. Und alle Möglichkeiten, die es gibt, die ja auch Teil des Programms sind, wie zum Beispiel ein Startabbruch oder ein Triebwerk ausfällt, was es für Möglichkeiten gibt, das Shuttle mitsamt den Astronauten zu retten. Glücklicherweise mussten sie nie genutzt werden. Das heißt also, es gab einen Flug, da ist nach sechs Minuten ein Haupttriebwerk ausgefallen. Da war aber die Besatzung noch in der Lage, die Tanks abzuwerfen und noch auf einen niedrigeren Orbit zu kommen und konnte dort sogar ihre Mission zu Ende führen. Also das war das einzige Mal, dass man so etwas genutzt hat. Dann gab es immer noch die Möglichkeit...
Welche Mission war das?
Wenn ich das wüsste, weiß ich nicht. Hab ich nicht genau.
Die haben vielleicht noch zusammengeklappt.
Oder so etwas. Dann gab es die Möglichkeit, die sogenannten Aborts, die Landeplätze an anderer Stelle, nicht Kennedy, Edwards oder White Sands. Es gab auch noch die Möglichkeit, in Europa gibt es Notlandehäfen. Die werden jetzt immer noch vor einem Shuttle-Start genauso geprüft wie alle anderen. Wie Kennedy Space Center. Die müssen ja dann in der Lage sein, wettermäßig auch das Shuttle aufnehmen zu können. Das gibt dann also Moron und istre in Frankreich und Moron und noch einen in Spanien. Ist aber auch nie genutzt worden. Und es gab sogar noch für die Möglichkeit eines anderen Orbits, die Möglichkeit war sogar mal Köln-Wonnen als Notlandeplatz vorgesehen. Landen konnten sie, hätten sie gekonnt, aber sie hätten nie mehr weggekonnt. Das ist klar. Das Shuttle muss ja dann, es ist ja so, wenn der Shuttle nicht in Kennedy landen kann, was ja durchaus auch mal vorkommt, dann landet er in Edwards. Und dann wird er, um ihn wieder vorzubereiten, auf eine umgebaute 747 gesetzt, den sogenannten SCA Shuttle-Craft Carrier, also so glaube ich, in der Art heißt es. Und das war übrigens meine erste Huckepack sozusagen. Und das wird dann gemacht, um ihn zurückzubringen, zurück zu Kennedy. Shuttle Carrier Aircraft heißt er, SCA. Und so ein Ding war ja auch mal zusammen mit einem Vorflugmodell, mit so einem Flugmodell des Shuttles mal hier in Deutschland. Er war dann auf so einer Rundreise, so eine PR-Rundreise, dieser Carrier mit Enterprise obendrauf. Und das war eigentlich das erste Mal, wo ich so einen Shuttle gesehen hab.
Aber von Cullen-Bonn könnte der SCA das Ding nicht über den Teich kriegen, oder was?
Doch, doch, doch ist er.
Also sie würden ihn schon wieder zurückkriegen. Der müsste jetzt ja immer an Cullen-Bonn bleiben.
Ja, aber die hätten ja, ich weiß nicht, dann müssten sie die Möglichkeit haben, den draufzusetzen auf die Maschine, wie das gemacht werden würde, auf diesen, weiß ich nicht.
Hätten sie erstmal was erfinden müssen.
Oder die Möglichkeiten, ob die da die Möglichkeiten haben, so einen Shuttle dann auf diese Maschine drauf zu tun, weiß ich nicht.
Ja, oder Schiff oder so, hätte wahrscheinlich gedauert.
Aber dieser Carrier kann ja auch nur, muss also immer gucken, dass er möglichst bei gutem Wetter fliegt und...
Also auch sowas muss bereit sein. Man denkt ja immer nur so, naja, das kleine Raketchen und so, das kriegen wir schon wieder hoch. Aber es ist eine riesen Infrastruktur drum herum. Flughäfen, die bereitgehalten werden müssen, zahlreiche Kontrollstationen etc., wie das ja auch für viele andere Missionen ähnlich ist. Aber am Ende hat es alles viel gekostet. Jetzt komme ich wieder ein bisschen zurück. Wir haben es ja hier vorhin, sind wir jetzt ein bisschen auf die Sicherheitstechnik abgebogen, sodass die Amerikaner ein bisschen versäumt haben, sich was Neues einfallen zu lassen. Jetzt ist es so, dass für die eigentlichen Satelliten-Starts, wo der Shuttle auch mal für verwendet werden sollte, ist der Weg irgendwie klar. Da werden dann auch vor allem kommerzielle Anbieter genommen, die in letzter Zeit auch nicht so besonders erfolgreich waren bei dem Launchen ihrer Raketen, aber so oder so die Art der Technologie, die jetzt im nächsten Jahrzehnt zumindest vornehmlich zum Einsatz kommen wird, ist irgendwie klar. Die Frage ist natürlich für diesen Forschungsbereich, auch jenseits der ISS-bezogenen Sachen, was steht denn an? Was betrifft ja auch nicht nur die NASA, sondern ist ja mittlerweile auch eigentlich eine internationale Aufgabe. Man macht ja schon gar nicht mehr so selber. Was fehlt denn jetzt? Wo möchte man denn hin?
Jetzt in Bezug auf die Raumstation?
Nee, in Bezug auf die, was auch immer der Nachfolger eine Shuttle sein könnte oder was überhaupt der Bedarf ist.
Also sicherlich, was erstmal ist, wie gesagt, ich hatte ja gesagt, USA ist ein tiefes Loch eingefallen. Sie sind jetzt abhängig von dem, was den Astronautentransport anbelangt, abhängig von den Russen, wenngleich schon eine ganze Weile mit dem Shuttle keine ISS-Crew mehr ausgetauscht worden ist. Das heißt, man hat eigentlich in den letzten drei Jahren, glaube ich drei Jahren, den Shuttle gar nicht mehr zum Austausch benutzt. Sondern man hat alles über Sojus gemacht. Und seitdem, seit 2009, seitdem die Raumstation also energiemäßig soweit auch in der Lage war, auch mehr Leute aufzunehmen und man sechs Leute oben hat, sind ja jetzt auch immer zwei Sojus oben, zwei Sojus-Rettungskapseln immer permanent angedockt, die immer in der Lage sind, auch die sechs Leute runterzukriegen. Was immer, was die Wissenschaft vor allen Dingen, ich finde, was die Wissenschaft vor allen Dingen betrifft, ist, wir haben immer die Möglichkeit, bislang auch mit dem Shuttle gehabt, viel hoch zu bekommen und konnten dann auch entsprechend Ergebnisse wieder runter bekommen, viel. Das heißt auch Geräte, Experimentgeräte, die sonst, die sonst, was man sonst nicht runter bekam. Der Shuttle, das ist jetzt nicht mehr der Fall. Wir haben jetzt zurzeit nur die Möglichkeit mit Sojus, mit der Sojus-Kapsel, da, wenn die runterkommen, ein paar Kilo als Beiladung reinzutun. Was uns fehlt, ist ein wieder eintrittsfähiger System, durchaus eine Kapsel auch, die auch uns in die Lage versetzt, mehr an Dingen wieder auf die Erde zu bringen, als es jetzt nach dem Shuttle sein wird. Und das ist das, was überall und was auch Europa untersucht. Wir untersuchen ja auch einen wieder eintrittsfähigen, zur Zeit läuft eine Studie bei der ESA jetzt ganz neu. Auch während der Le Bourget von Dordain wohl gesagt worden, dass es wird ein Vehikel entwickelt bis 2013, das dann nachweisen kann, dass es soweit sein kann, dass es dann wieder eintritt machen kann, eine Kapsel, die also auch mehr an Nutzlast mitnehmen kann. Wir haben uns fehlt, uns fehlt, und das wird Europa auch nicht machen können, wie die Astronauten in Zukunft auf die Raumstation kommen. Die Amerikaner sind dabei, ihre Raumfahrt auch zu kommerzialisieren, das heißt, nichts mehr oder das nicht mehr, alles nur selbst zu machen institutionell, sondern es an Industrie zu geben, von dem man dann so ein System später dann mal wieder leasen oder mieten könnte. Also es ist ja zur Zeit, die letzten drei, vier Jahre läuft das ja schon, eins kann ich nur nennen, eben die Firma SpaceX, die ja schon relativ weit ist mit ihrer Falcon 9, mit ihrer Rakete, die ja auch schon geflogen ist, und im Dezember letzten Jahres ist ja auch ihre Kapsel, die Dragon-Kapsel ist ja auch schon geflogen, und die will man dann eben auch so weit aufmotzen, dass sie bis, ich glaube, Ende 2013 die Möglichkeit hat, an der Raumstation anzudocken, aber als Frachtversion, und später dann sie weiterentwickeln will, um auch Astronauten zu pflegen. Aber das sieht der Senat nicht so gerne, und auch die Leute, die natürlich auch die NASA und ihren Fittichen haben, und die gucken, die Senatoren und auch die entsprechenden Staaten in Amerika, und die wollen natürlich schon, dass die NASA auch ihr eigenes System entwickelt. Es gab ja damals das Constellation-System, was ja dann wieder abgesagt worden ist, mit diesen Raketen Ares und Ares V.
Das war eigentlich der Kandidat als Nachfolger des Shuttle-Programms.
Ja, und auch das Nachfolgesystem des Space, des Shuttles, sollte ja eine Rakete sein, die aus großen Teilen dessen besteht, was auch an den Shuttle dran war. Also die Teil der Feststoffraketen will man, glaube ich, benutzen. Zurzeit ist das alles noch in der Schwebe. Auf jeden Fall muss sich auch die NASA jetzt in die Pötte kommen. Das heißt, der Senat hat jetzt angefordert, dass NASA entsprechende Unterlagen liefert. Wie sie denn gedenkt, die NASA jetzt diesen Gap, diese Lücke bis zu einem neuen System schließen will. Wie schnell. Man will ja möglichst nicht zu lange von den Russen abhängig sein. Obwohl ich sagen muss, mit der Raumstation und mit dem Einbinden der Russen, ich hab das früher auch nicht gedacht, von 1998, aber ich glaube, die Russen sind ein sehr zuverlässiger Partner. Das hört man überall. Sie fühlen sich auch dort oben sehr eingebunden. Sie wissen, dass sie unverzichtbar sind. Sie lassen sich das natürlich auch bezahlen, klar, die Sitze. Es gibt jetzt erst wohl bis Ende 2013 einen Vertrag mit den Russen, um amerikanische Astronauten dort hoch zu bringen. Wie gesagt, wie es jetzt weitergeht, auch dann, was nach der ISS kommt 2020, welches System im Endeffekt kommt, es wird höchstwahrscheinlich ein Kapselsystem sein. Wieder ein System mit einer Rakete und einer Kapsel oben drauf, wo man auch in der Lage ist, bei Bedarf, bei Gefahr, auch die Astronauten sicher von der Rakete wegzubekommen. Das macht die Sache natürlich auch preiswerter insgesamt. Man hat dann natürlich wieder die Wegwerfrakete, aber an sich wird das Programm billiger.
Ja, und sicherer. Und sicherer. Das heißt, eigentlich ist alles auf die ISS ausgerichtet. Diese ganze Planung ist eigentlich immer in der Annahme, jetzt geht es erstmal um Raumstation.
Zur Zeit geht es natürlich erstmal zu ISS. Man denkt natürlich an ISS and beyond, wie es so schön ist und was kommt danach. Es gab ja die Exploration-Initiative, der Amerikaner von Bush damals, wo man sagt, möglicherweise über die Raumstation hinaus, back to the moon, zurück zum Mond. Und dann als fernes, weites Ziel mal den Mars dann auch bemannt, wo man dann schon sagt, 2035, aber noch viel weiter nach hinten. Ob das alles mal, oder ob man vielleicht mal zu Kometen in der Zwischenzeit geht oder zu Asteroiden, was ja auch interessant ist. Also die Möglichkeit, das wird natürlich schon untersucht, auch bei der ESA sehr stark, diese Exploration beyond ISS. Was haben wir nach ISS?
Aber bei der ESA ist das ja auch voll im Rollen, mit der Rosetta-Mission der Zeit.
Ja, aber ich denke jetzt an die bemannte Raumfahrt. Daher heißt es wirklich, warum, da gibt es dann natürlich die Frage, warum zurück zum Mond, wir waren ja schon mal da.
Aber es geht eher darum, den Mond als Basisstation zu verwenden. Das ist ja auch so ein klassischer Science-Fiction-Traum. Mondbasis Alpha 1 habe ich auch mal gesehen, als ich noch jung war im Fernsehen, da läuft man dann immer rum. Aber der Vorteil ist ja, man kann von da gut, also wenn man es schafft, von da gut zu starten, hat man einfach den Vorteil, dass man nicht mit so viel Gravitation zu tun hat.
Genau, genau. Und es gibt dann noch dazwischen die Punkte, dass man sagt, wir auf dem Weg, es gibt ja auch noch bestimmte Punkte zwischen Erde und Mond, die man anfliegen könnte, die energetisch auch sehr günstig für Raumfahrzeuge sind, wo man zum Beispiel, sagen wir mal, eine Tankstelle unterbringen könnte oder sowas. Also solche Sachen. Aber das ist Dinge, die sind nicht mehr, die waren nicht mehr in meinem Berit jetzt auch. Das kommt jetzt alles. Ich hoffe, dass ich das alles vielleicht auch noch erheben kann.
Jetzt haben wir so viel über Vergangenheit geredet. Jetzt kann man sich ja auch ruhig mal ein bisschen auf die Zukunft einschließen. Zumal es ja eben auch gerade eine Phase ist in der Internationalen Raumfahrt, wo einfach die neuen Ideen wieder gefragt sind. Man hat sich jetzt lange, also vieles von dem, was bisher war, ist jetzt ausgelaufen. Deswegen reden wir jetzt auch gerade hier darüber, Space Shuttle, das ist jetzt halt einfach mal das Ende einer Ära ist jetzt gekommen. Und neue Ähren stehen quasi an. Ja, die Ära der ISS ist sicherlich noch lange nicht vorbei. Was war jetzt die letzte Verlängerung?
2020.
Hat sich jetzt Europa auch endlich dann dazu erkannt?
Genau, also mindestens, sag ich mal. Weiß der Geier, das könnte ja, das sind ja auch nur neun Jahre, das ist ja eigentlich nix. Und ich denke, die ISS hat auch so von dem, was ich so jetzt auch aus den letzten Gesprächen hier mitgenommen habe, sehr wohl Potenzial auch noch länger durchzuhalten. Das ist ja nicht so, dass sie dann schon auseinanderklappt, sondern ist ja eigentlich im besten Zustand. Fragt sich natürlich, ob Mars-Missionen jetzt wirklich dann mal noch Realität werden sollen oder nicht?
Also sicherlich, wenn. Ich mein, man kann sagen, alles ist wunderschön, auch so was zu machen. Die Leute gucken eben, die Regierungen vor allen Dingen, auch gucken aufs Geld. Und das wird natürlich nicht billig. Und deswegen, davon hat man sich ja schon vor geraumer Zeit verabschiedet, so was national oder europäisch stemmen zu können, solche Missionen. Sondern da ist wirklich die Kommunität der Welt gefragt. Da sind die großen Raumfahrtnationen gefragt. Und da kommen immer neue dazu. Und sonst kann man das nicht stemmen. Und ich glaube, da ist man eigentlich auf einem guten Weg, wenn man die nationalen Animositäten noch weiter in den Hintergrund rückt. Wissenschaftlich für so ein Ziel zusammenzuarbeiten, das wäre schon ganz toll. Und ich glaube, da gibt es gute Ansätze. Da gibt es wirklich gute Ansätze.
Jetzt auf jeden Fall ist dann erstmal noch ein bisschen wehmütiger Blick nach hinten angesagt. Ich meine, mit dem Space Shuttle verliert man ja nicht nur eine Technologie. Ich finde auch, dass eigentlich Space Shuttle wie vielleicht mit der Ausnahme der Mondlandung so sehr als Ikone der Raumfahrt gewirkt hat. Also der startende Shuttle oder auch der landende Shuttle. Also das Ding hatte ja auch einfach eine Ästhetik mitgebracht. Die war einfach erstaunlich. Das können die Amerikaner ja auch immer super.
Das wird auch gut vermarktet.
Das hatten sie schon irgendwie immer drauf. Aber das hat das eben auch geleistet. Damit verliert ja die Raumfahrt auch so ein bisschen so ein Maskottchen.
Das ist richtig. Ich glaube, wer wirklich mal, wer so einen Start live gesehen hat, jeder hat es versucht, gerade auch natürlich unter Kollegen und es gibt ja auch selbst Touristen, die nur anrufen und sagen, hier könnt ihr mir nicht sagen, wie komme ich denn da hin und können mir das mal angucken. Aber wer mal einen Nachtstart gesehen hat, eine Shuttle, vielleicht wenn wir eine ganz kurze Zeit haben. Eine ganz nette Episode ist, ich war zu der Zeit, wo ich mich auf die EINES, auf die Experimente vorbereitet habe, war man immer so wochenlang dann auch mal in Amerika am Cape, in einem bestimmten Bereich, der nannte sich Hangar LSSF, Life Science Support Facility. Dort wurden zusammen mit den amerikanischen Kollegen die Experimente vorbereitet, bevor sie dann vor dem Start in Space Lab, in den Shuttle geladen wurden. Und wir wollten natürlich unbedingt die EINES möglichst nahe starten sehen. Und als es dann soweit war, wir sind nicht mehr bis zum Start, also zu der WIP-Äre, wo man die Visitor-Äre sieht, gekommen, weil wir noch wirklich bis zum Ende der Vorbereitung da sein mussten, aber dann sagte uns ein Kollege, kommt mit, wir gehen 200 Meter auf den NASA Parkway East. Und da seht ihr das ganz, ganz doll, da habt ihr einen sagenhaften Blick. Und dann sind wir da hingegangen und dann sieht man ganz, ganz in der Ferne, es sind 12 Kilometer, sieht man ganz in der Ferne, sieht man also das Startgerüst mit dem Shuttle. Aber das Interessante ist dann, dann sehen sie beim Start, sehen sie plötzlich eine riesen Wolke, aber sie hören noch nichts. Weil der Schall, und dann kommt ein Knistern auf einen zu, es knistert in den Ohren, es geht bis in den Kopf rein, es geht wie, wie, wie, es geht in die Haarspitzen rein und dann gibt es einen riesen, dann kommt der Schall nach und dann sieht man wie aus dieser Wolke, dann dieser Shuttle in den Himmel steigt nach Nordosten, immer der ISS nach und das ist fantastisch. Es ist laut, es ist sehr, sehr laut. Also man, ich würde sagen so, das geht so an die 100 Dezibel. Also da, in der Entfernung.
In 12 Kilometern Entfernung?
In 12 Kilometern Entfernung.
Wow, also das lohnt sich da sozusagen auch noch. Das knallt richtig.
Das knallt richtig, ja.
Tja, na die Gelegenheit ist jetzt verstrichen, so Shuttle. Jetzt kann man sich nur noch Ariane angucken, nicht ganz so leicht zu erreichen. Zumindest nicht so eine Touristengegend da unten im Urwald, aber stimmt auch mal ganz interessant.
Sicherlich.
Haben wir es, wa?
Ich glaube, wir haben eigentlich soweit alles grob abgedeckt. Es gibt ja so viel, und es gibt ja so viel, auch gerade für die Zuhörer, es gibt ja so viel Literatur über die ganze Geschichte zu lesen. So viele Leute haben sehr gute Bücher geschrieben, auch gerade über die Raumfahrt bemannte Raumfahrt, auch über Space Shuttle gibt es sehr gute, auch im Internet sehr gute Möglichkeiten, sich zu informieren, wenn man eben meint, man hätte noch was, es fehlt noch was. Aber ich bin kein Techniker von Hause aus, ich bin eigentlich über die Wissenschaft reingekommen. Der Shuttle hat mich eben nur begleitet, hat, was heißt nur, er hat mich wirklich während meines fast 80 Prozent meines Berufslebens begleitet. Und deswegen möchte ich es auch nicht missen. Und deswegen hat man auch, man hat natürlich auch Kollegen, die sich dann mehr mit der Infrastruktur beschäftigen, mehr mit der Technik, der Systeme. Aber man kriegt eben auch so einiges mit und ich hoffe, es ist einiges rübergekommen.
Auf jeden Fall. Und wir sind ja auch hier im Internet mit unserem kleinen Podcast und werden hier noch so einige Geschichten hoffentlich zusammenkratzen. Zumal wir jetzt auch so viele Barsysteme schon hier bearbeitet haben, dass dann so die Möglichkeit eröffnet, noch weiter ins Detail zu schauen. Aber das ist dann alles nicht mehr Thema der heutigen Sendung, die Nummer 19 zum Space Shuttle. Vielen Dank Volker Sobek.
Gerne, hat mir Spaß gemacht.
Und wie immer auch vielen Dank hier beim Zuhören und vielleicht auch zum Kommentieren bei uns im Blog. Wir hören immer gerne, wie die Sendungen angekommen sind, was wir sonst noch machen könnten, etc., Und in diesem Sinne, Tim Pritlove, ich sag Tschüss und bis bald bei Raumzeit.